[MUSIC PLAYING]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
is not how computer science works.
And indeed, by the end
of today, we'll make
clear exactly what's right,
what's not right about that,
and hopefully give you some pause any
time you watch TV or movies hereafter
and notice these little things
that all too many writers seem
to take for granted.
So recall that last time, we took a look
lower level at what compiling actually
is.
And recall that it was a few things,
these four steps of pre-processing
and compiling and
assembling and linking,
so that when you start
with their source cod,
that might look like this code
that we have written in the past,
you first have to preprocess it, and
the first step in pre-processing was
converting all of those
processor instructions--
anything starting with a hash at the
beginning-- to their equivalents.
So opening the files and effectively
copying and pasting the contents
there so that programs and the
compiler know what get_string
is and know what printf is.
The next step that came
after that was actually
compiling, whereby compiling
technically means taking that source
code, once it's been preprocessed,
and printing and generating
this very cryptic-looking
stuff called assembly code.
And those assembly codes or assembly
instructions are really what the CPU--
the brain of your computer--
actually understands,
although technically the computer
understands them only in the form
of 0's and 1's.
And so when you "assemble-- step three--
that assembly code, you actually
get out those 0's and 1's.
But even that simplest of programs where
we just prompt the user for a string
and then print out their name
still involved a couple more files.
There was not only cs50.h
and stdio.h at the top,
somewhere in the computer system
there's probably files called cs50.c,
and in the case of stdio, printf.c,
in which actually the code is
for those two functions, those
two have to get compiled down
to 0's and 1's, and then we need
to link everything together,
merging those 0's and 1's so that
the computer has access to your code
and to printf's code and to the
cs50 library's code And so forth.
But all of that we can just generally
wrap up in the descriptor of compiling.
And so that's one of the
looks we took last week.
And we also have introduced, last
week and previously, a few tools.
And odds are, you're having as
many frustrations perhaps already
with the p-sets as you
are accomplishments
and sense of satisfaction.
And that's normal, and rest assured
that the scales will eventually tip more
toward happiness and away
from sadness, but we'll
give you indeed more tools today
than these for actually finding
problems or shortcomings in your code.
help50, recall, helps
you with what process?
When you instinctively
consider using help50?
When you see error
messages on the screen.
Something you don't understand
that's the result of some mistake you
probably made but you don't quite
understand what the computer is telling
you, run help50, and then that
same command and we, the staff,
with our code will try to
understand the message for you
and provide you with feedback.
style50 does exactly that.
It helps you see with red and green
color coding exactly what spaces should
be there, shouldn't be there--
it just helps you pretty
your code so that you can read it
better and other humans can as well.
And then printf, which is kind of like
the coarsest tool in your tool box,
this is just helping you see not
only messages you want to see,
but just the values of variables.
You can print ints and
strings, whatever you want,
and then you can delete
those lines of printf
once you're confident
your program's working.
But that gets a little tedious, and
honestly, as our programs get bigger,
we're going to want more powerful tools
than like manually printing things
out, recompiling, rerunning, it
very quickly it gets tedious.
And the goal of programming is not
to be tedious, but to be empowering,
and that's where we'll
step to today via this.
So CS50 IDE is sort of
fancier version of what
you've been using called CS50
Sandbox, and in turn, CS50 Lab.
Now recall that both of those
tools, the Sandbox and the Lab,
have a terminal window
where you can type commands,
they have a code editor where
you can actually write your code,
and then they have a file
browser with icons and such
where you can actually see
your files and folders.
So it turns out that CS50 IDE is
another tool that at first glance
is very, very similar, even though
it's laid out a little differently,
but it has as many features as the
Sandbox and the Lab, but some more.
More features that actually help
you solve problems in your code
and even collaborate come final project
time with others if you would like.
So this we'll see is
this is the CS50 IDE.
It comes with the
so-called night mode so you
can make everything a little darker on
your screen, especially if p-setting
at night, and let's
actually take a look then
at what you can do
with this kind of tool.
When you log into this tool for the
very first time in the next problem set,
you'll see an interface that's
almost the same as before.
The colors are a little different,
the font sizes are a little different,
but at the bottom by default, you
have your so-called terminal window,
though instead of the
dollar sign now, you'll
see a little more detailed
workspace, but more on that in a bit.
Up here you just have
the code editor window,
nothing's really going on there.
And then we have the added
feature of Ceiling Cat
in the top right-hand corner.
And we'll also see some
other features along the way.
So let's actually write a program
in CS50 IDE, which, to be clear,
is just another web-based programming
environment that also gives you
access to your own cloud-based server.
It, too, is running Ubuntu Linux, which
is a popular operating system that
is not macOS and it's not Windows.
But unlike the sandbox environment
where you don't even log in
and you lose your files
eventually, as you
may know from when your cookies
are lost or something goes wrong,
the IDE saves everything.
And you'll log in with
your account, and whatever
you put there last week is going
to be there this week and next week
and beyond.
So let me go ahead up to File, New File,
or I could just click this little plus
icon in the top right-hand corner, and
let me go ahead and preemptively hit
Control-S or Command-S
or go to File, Save--
you should find the interface very
similar to any Mac or PC program--
and let me go ahead and
save this file as follows.
I'm going to call this hello.c.
And it's important to
mention the file extension,
otherwise the IDE, like
the Sandbox and the Lab,
won't know what type of
program you're writing.
And then let me go ahead and just
write my simplest of programs.
So let me go ahead and include
stdio.h, int main void.
Let me go ahead and open
my curly braces, printf--
hello, world, backslash
n, and a semi-colon.
So you'll notice that almost
everything is the same.
The colors are a little
different, perhaps,
and you might see some
different assistive
features as you're typing your code,
but the end result is the same.
And the color coding you just
get for free because it's helping
draw your attention to
different parts of the code.
Let me go ahead now and--
oh notice this.
There's one difference.
The IDE is a more powerful tool,
but as such, it's a more manual tool
and it's not just going to
auto-save your code for you.
Nice as that's been with the
Sandbox, such that you'd never
actually had the hit
Command-S or Control-S--
and if you were, you
didn't need to be, the IDE
is only going to save things when
you want it to so that nothing
will happen magically anymore.
So what I'm going to have to do is go
back up here, File, Save, or Command-S
or Control-S, you'll
see a little green dot
briefly, and now and back at my prompt.
I'm going to go ahead now and type my
familiar command, make hello, Enter,
and you'll see pretty much the
same cryptic-looking client
command as before because the IDE is
configured quite like the Sandbox.
And if I want to go ahead and run
this now, how do I run this program?
Quick check?
./hello, it's exactly
the same as before.
./hello, and there we
have it, hello, world.
So long story short, the user interface
thus far is a little different,
but functionally it's the same.
We're just going to now start
to see some more features.
So what are those features?
And let's introduce new some
capabilities that were actually
possible in the Sandbox, we just didn't
really introduce them at the time.
If I click this folder icon at top left,
you'll see all of my files and folders.
And today for lecture I have
a lot of pre-made examples
that are already on the course's
website, some of which we'll look at,
some of which we'll
refer to the website,
but these are just
familiar files and folders.
And you can see that
everything in my account
is apparently in something
called Workspace, which
is just a folder, name, or a directory.
Here's my sc3 directory,
which again, comes
from the website for
today's lecture, lecture 3.
And then here's the file I just
compiled in the program and the file
that I wrote, hello.c.
You'll notice too that there's
this funky symbol here, tilde,
that you might not have occasion
to write often in English,
but in Spanish in other languages
you might use this character.
This is actually a shorthand notation
for what's called your home directory.
In this environment, CS50 IDE, you
have your own home directory, which
means your folder of files and other
folders that you get to create,
you own, and that persists every
time you log in-- you're not
going to lose the contents therein.
So this just means that in your
home directory, a.k.a. tilde,
there is a folder called workspace
in which I'm currently working.
And that's just one folder in which
all of my work is going to be done,
because there's so many other files
and folders in this cloud environment,
just like there are in your
Mac and PC, we just generally
don't care what they are.
But notice what we can do at this
terminal window besides compile
and run code.
There are other commands.
For instance, this blue text here,
similarly to the file browser up top,
indicates now not just that this
is my prompt per the dollar sign,
but that in my home directory's
workspace directory.
So that means I can be
elsewhere even though I haven't
specified where I want to go yet.
And in fact, I can do
this. ls stands for list,
it's just shorthand notation for that.
And now I see a textual version
of my file tree, so to speak.
So you'll see here, sc3
is a folder, and you
can tell as much because there's
a slash at the end of it.
hello.c is of course the
file I wrote a moment ago.
And then hello in green is my
program that I compiled, and the star
or asterisk there is just--
it's not the name of the file,
it's just indicating to me
visually that that is executable.
That's a program I can run
just so I know what's compiled
and what maybe is source code.
So when you're running ./hello, the
reason all this time this has been
working is because in dot, your current
folder, there is a file called hello,
and when you hit Enter, you
are running that program there.
So if after today you go back onto
CS50 Sandbox or CS50 Lab and type ls,
you'll see exactly the same thing
as you might by the little folder
icon in those programs as well.
But suppose I want to
go into a directory.
In macOS or Windows or even
the IDE, I could, of course,
go my File icon, and then
per the little triangle
here, which might seem
intuitive, you just click it
and you can see what's going
on inside, not surprising.
But how do you do that textually?
At a command prompt, well
it's not all that hard.
You just need to change your directory.
So if I do cd space sc3, Enter,
nothing seems to happen quite yet
except that my prompt changed.
Here's the indication that-- this
is my prompt, but to the left of it
you see in blue that I'm now in my
home directory's workspace folder,
in my sc3 folder there.
So it's just a text-based version of
the GUIs, the Graphical User Interfaces
that all of us have
certainly come to take
for granted in the world of
macOS and Windows thus far.
Well, suppose that I'm a little
done with my hello program
and I want to delete it.
Well in the IDE, like in the Sandbox,
you can actually go up here and you can
click on it, and then you can
typically right-click or control-click,
and you'll get a whole menu of other
options, one of which is Delete--
and feel free to tinker like
that in your own environment.
But what about the command line?
If I zoom in down here and I
want to remove hello, you're
not going to type remove because
that just feels a little verbose
and humans decades ago decided
that's too tedious to type,
let's just call this command rm--
for remove-- hello, you're going
to see a somewhat cryptic prompt.
rm-- remove regular file 'hello?'
This is more arcane than it needs
to be, but it's just asking,
are you sure you want to delete 'hello?'
Then it's just waiting for you.
And here you can type y or yes
or sometimes other commands too,
now I've confirmed that
my intentions were yes.
If I type ls again, I--
whoops, in the wrong folder.
If I type ls again after doing hello--
no-- after doing hello
and do ls, now I'll
see just those two
things-- sc3 and hello.c.
What if I want to make a folder?
Well notice this.
If I type at the bottom
here, make directory--
mkdir-- test just to
make a test folder, I'm
about to hit Enter, but watch
the top left-hand corner
where I currently have those other
files and folders, and when I hit Enter,
now I have a test folder.
So these things are identical.
One is graphical, one is command
line, and there's even other commands
if I decide I don't want that.
rmdir is remove directory,
and it just goes away
because it's empty and thus safe.
Any questions then on
any of those commands
or just the overall layout of
what it is we're looking at?
All right, so don't get hung
up on any of those commands,
and the problem set
and beyond will always
remind you of those kinds of features.
The point for now is just that
we're in a somewhat new environment,
but it's fundamentally still the
same, it has the same capabilities.
So what are other tools we looked at?
So you might have heard rumors about
a tool called check50, and indeed,
this is a tool that the staff use to
evaluate problem set 1 and problems set
2 to evaluate the correctness of them
so that we ourselves don't have to type
./mario or ./caesar again and again
and again to test students' code.
But starting this week, you, too,
have access to the same program.
check50 is a command from the staff
that checks the correctness of your code
just like style50 checks
the style of your code.
And in fact, if I go
back over to my IDE,
let's try to use this for the first
time by making the same version of hello
that you did perhaps for
your first problem set.
So if I go ahead and include
not just stdio, but cs50.h,
and I go ahead and get
a string from the user
with get_string, prompting them
for their name, and then go ahead
and print not just hello, world,
but hello, percent s comma name,
this I believe was the same
program you yourselves probably
wrote, or some variant thereof.
So if I go ahead now
and test this myself--
make hello, Enter, seems OK, ./hello.
I'm going to go ahead and type in
my name, and voila, hello, David.
Now suppose you're feeling
pretty good, you're
pretty confident that
your code is correct,
and most importantly, you have
tested your code yourselves.
It's not sufficient to
rely on our tool alone
to test your code because it,
too, might not be exhaustive.
So once you've tried a few inputs,
not just David, but perhaps
Veronica's name as well, seems to work.
Brian's name as well, seems to work.
No name at all, doesn't
seem to work, maybe?
But we'll have to look
back to the problem set
to see if that's actually a problem.
Let me go ahead now and run check50.
check50 expects a special
slug, so to speak.
Just a unique identifier for the
problem that you want to check.
And you would only know
this from reading a problem
set or a documentation online.
I just happened to recall that the
command that the staff had been using
to grade and evaluate hello
is just cs50/2018/fall/hello.
And the slash is to just kind of
visually distinguish those words,
this isn't a folder or files or
anything like that in your own account.
So I'm going to run check50
cs50/2018/fall/hello in the same
directory that hello.c is in.
Enter.
It's going to go ahead and connect
to GitHub, which is the backend,
recall, that we use
for storing your code.
It's authenticating me now, which means
what's your username and password?
I'm going to go ahead and
use one of my test accounts.
And now it's prompting
me for my password,
and I'm going to go
ahead and type that in.
You'll notice you're seeing stars
like you see bullets in a website
just so that someone looking over your
shoulder can't see what you're typing.
Now I'm going to go ahead
and watch the progress.
It's preparing, let me
go ahead and zoom in.
Dot-dot-dot.
It's looking at my code, it's
getting ready for submission,
it's now uploading it to GitHub.com,
and once it's on the servers,
then it's going to tell CS50 server,
here is so-and-so's submission,
go ahead and run a few
automated tests on it,
checking therefore its correctness,
and hopefully we're about to see some
green, happy smiley
faces, and voila, yes,
it looks like this check50
command for this problem--
or slug, so to speak--
checked that hello.c exists, because
if I forgot to write the file
or if I misnamed it,
nothing's going to work.
We checked that it
compiles successfully,
so that, too, is a happy green face.
Then it apparently checked--
what if we type in Veronica?
Do we see hello, Veronica?
Apparently yes.
What if we typed in another word, Brian?
Yes, apparently we say hello, Brian.
And so with high
probability, we're going
to conclude, based on those four tests,
that your code is, in fact, correct,
at least with respect to those inputs.
And there's often some more
detail via URL at the bottom
where you can actually see
more graphically just more
feedback on your code.
Of course, the first time, second time,
third time maybe you run this command,
you might not see some
green happy faces,
you might see some red unhappy
faces or some yellow flat faces,
which just means we couldn't even run
the checks because something else is
wrong.
But over time, this will help you feel
more comfortable and more confident
that your code's correct before you
actually use submit50 and submit.
Going into it you'll feel a little
better or a little frustrated
to know in advance-- wait a minute,
I'm about to submit this but nope,
it's not yet correct.
So realize it's a two-edged sword.
Any questions about check50 or
any of these commands thus far?
Anything at all?
No?
All right.
So let's take a look at
the final and most powerful
tool now available to you
in the IDE environment.
Built in to CS50 IDE, which
stands for Integrated Development
Environment, which isn't a CS50 thing--
this is a common term in industry
for tools that make it
easier to write code,
it turns out that there's some other
feature besides the cat over here.
Namely, one, you can
share your workspace
with teaching fellows
and course assistants
so they can perhaps help you in real
time a la Google Docs, even chatting
with you in real time.
But it also provides you with
what's called a debugger.
A debugger, as the name
suggests, removes bugs--
or rather, helps you
remove bugs from your code
by allowing you to not
just resort to printf--
printing out ints and
strings and whatever
is good that's going on your
program, it kind of automates
that very tedious process for you.
And it lets you walk
through your code one
line at a time at your
own comfortable pace
and see along the way all of the values
of your variables in that program.
To activate this debugger, I'm going
to go ahead and do the following.
I'm going to compile my code
as always with make hello.
It has to compile,
otherwise I might want
to use help50 and figure
out why it's not compiling,
but it does seem to have compiled.
And now I'm going to go ahead
and run debug50, space, and then
the name of the program
I wanted to debug.
And the name of the program I
wanted to debug at the moment
is the current directory's
file called hello.
Let's assume that there's
perhaps something wrong with it.
The first time I run this
command, though, debug50
is not going to be happy with
me because it's going to say,
it looks like you haven't
set any breakpoints.
Set at least one breakpoint by
clicking to the left of a line number
and then rerun debug50.
Well what is a breakpoint?
Well as the name kind
of suggests, it allows
you to break or pause the running
of your code at any of your lines.
And all this time for
the past few weeks,
your code been
automatically line-numbered.
And this is useful because the most
interesting line in this program,
once it really gets going,
isn't this stuff at the top,
it's not int main void, right?
That's all copy-paste
from past programs.
It's really the sixth line here where
I actually have some logic of my own.
And so in CS50 IDE,
what you can now do is
click to the left of one
of these line numbers,
a little red light like a stop
sign is going to appear saying,
break or pause my
program on this line so
that I can poke around my actual code.
Sandbox and Lab cannot do this.
So now I'm going to go ahead and rerun
debug50 in exactly the same way, hit
Enter, but now I have one breakpoint.
And you'll see on the right-hand
side a fancier menu just popped up
by the cat that provides me
with a bunch of features.
And at first glance, frankly,
it's a little overwhelming
because there's a lot going on
here, but you'll notice first,
and most importantly, there's
some mention of my name variable.
I don't quite understand 0x0 or
whatnot, but I do understand string.
And so what the debug50 program has
realized is oh, on this line and below,
you have a variable called name.
It doesn't seem to have a value yet.
0x0, it turns out, is just going
to mean empty or null or 0.
But that's good, because now,
when I actually execute this line,
hopefully it's going to take on the
name David or Veronica or Brian.
So let's see what happens.
Notice that it's highlighted in
yellow, line 6, which means it
has not yet executed this line of code.
My code has paused at this point
because I set that breakpoint.
And then notice kind of like a music
player up here, there's a few icons.
The Play button is just going
to say, ah, play my program,
run it all the way through the end, kind
of like scratch with the green flag.
But more powerful is this.
You can step over this line,
therefore executing it just once.
If it's a function, you
can step into this line
and actually look inside of a function
that you're using, like get_string,
or you can step out of another
function, but more on that another time.
So what I'm going to do is this.
And the button I'm going to click most
commonly when trying to understand
how my program is working is this--
Step Over.
So it's the second icon from the
left, right next to the triangle.
So once I click this, watch
what's going to happen,
even though it's a little small, on the
right-hand side for my name variable.
Notice that I'm being prompted to
type in my name because the program
is still running in my terminal
window, but when I hit Enter now,
providing my own name, automatically
you see on the right-hand side
that this name variable has a
value now of, quote-unquote,
"David" of type string.
There's this 0x1083010-- more on
that later, just a little cryptic,
but I didn't have to use printf now,
I can actually see what's going on.
Now you can see that
line 7 is highlighted,
because I set a breakpoint above
it, so now I'm on the second line
because I just stepped into it.
Let me go ahead and click
Next again, and you'll
see that in my terminal window,
hello, David just got executed.
And now if I just keep going, it's
going to go ahead and run to the end
and close the debugger.
So not all that useful for this
program because frankly, I'm
pretty sure this is correct, but the
power of debug50 and a debugger more
generally is that it lets you, whether
you're less comfy or more comfy,
walk through your own code at your pace
just like a TF or a CA might say, OK,
what is this line doing?
What is this line doing?
You don't have to resort to printf,
you can just very methodically
walk through your code and find that
damn bug that's been bothering you
for minutes or even hours.
So henceforth, any time you have a
bug in your code that is compiling
but it's just logically incorrect--
the pyramid in Mario isn't quite right,
your encryption of Caesar isn't
quite right, or something else,
your first instinct now should be,
let me compile it, run debug50 on it,
and just step through the code,
setting a breakpoint wherever I want,
so you focus on just a few
lines, not the whole thing--
like I just did--
and see if you can figure out logically
when a value is not what you expected,
then oh--
go ahead and just click
Resume, fix the bug, and retry.
Such a powerful tool.
Any questions?
Yeah?
What is it?
AUDIENCE: What does it look
like when there is a bug?
DAVID MALAN: What does it
look like when there is a bug?
So the debugger won't find your bugs
and it won't show you your bugs, per se.
It's going to let you see
what line is executing,
it's going to let you
see what's outputting,
take input, but all it's
going to do on that
right-hand side is just show
you the values of things along the way.
It's up to you to infer
from that information what
it is that's going wrong, just like
if you're using printf in past weeks
to see what's going on in your program.
Other questions?
And let me save this too.
It is so easy to get into the habit,
especially when so many things have
been new over the past few
weeks of just saying, ah,
this is just yet another thing to learn.
This is hands down the
kind of tool that if you
spend a few extra minutes this
week and next week just using it,
get a little more
comfortable with it, it
will save you potentially
hours in the long run,
because all the time you've
been spending manually
trying to fix your bugs or
posting questions online
trying to understand
things, this is a tool
that if you invest those
minutes upfront will just
help you understand everything
going on inside of your program,
and will absolutely over the next few
weeks save you more and more time.
All right, any questions? yeah?
AUDIENCE: So you have a for
loop that ran [INAUDIBLE] times,
[INAUDIBLE] separate break statements
so you don't have to [INAUDIBLE]..
DAVID MALAN: Ah, good question.
If you have something like a for
loop or a while loop, something
that's happening a lot, can you
set a breakpoint in such a way
that it only breaks so that you don't
have to walk through it 100 times
just to see that value?
Short answer, yes.
And let me defer to section and
online resources for just a few
of these features, but one,
you can actually watch values,
and you can have what's
called a watch expression.
You can say show me this value
if only when x is greater than 50
or something like that.
Or you yourself can just
add some lines of code.
You could add a, if x equals-equals
50, then print out something,
and you can set a breakpoint
on that new, if temporary line,
so there's a couple of ways to do that.
Good question to anticipate.
Yeah?
Behind.
AUDIENCE: If you run
debug50, aren't you adding
another arugment with the [INAUDIBLE]
in your main method at line 4?
DAVID MALAN: Really good question.
If you're running
debug50, aren't you adding
another argument-- argv-- per our
discussion last week of command line
arguments?
Short answer, no, because
debug50 corrects for that,
so you don't have to worry about that.
It will not shift
things over numerically.
Really good thought.
Other questions?
All right, so with that said, let's
now take some training wheels off.
So the only reason I bought
these training wheels years ago
is to make this very dramatic point
of now taking the training wheels off
today.
OK, so what does this mean?
Well worth the trip to Target.
So what does this mean?
For the past few weeks, we
have been using a whole bunch
of functions from CS50's library.
All of these were meant to just make
it pretty easy, relatively speaking,
in the first few weeks to
get input from the user.
Because it turns out,
as we'll see today,
it's actually a kind of a pain in the
neck to get input from users in C,
and frankly, even in other
languages reliability.
Because you'll recall that get_string
and get_int and all of these functions
take on the burden of like re-prompting
the user if they don't actually
give you an an int or
don't give you a float
or don't give you a char that
you're expecting, they'll re-prompt,
they're using a while loop or
a do-while loop or the like,
so there's just a lot of error
detection built into these functions.
But, most importantly--
and most misleadingly,
has been the last one on this list.
Recall that we introduced a couple
weeks ago now the notion of a string.
And a string is in English what?
An array of characters, good.
It's a sequence of characters, and we
learned last week that a sequence can
be implemented in an array,
which is just a chunk of memory
back-to-back-to-back-to-back.
So string, though, is not quite
like any of those other data types.
It turns out that it's not quite like
int or char or even bool or float,
and we can start to see
that now as follows.
I'm going to go ahead and
go into the IDE today--
and henceforth we're going
to just start using the IDE,
but you're welcome to keep using the
Sandbox for quick and dirty programs,
but for anything you
want to keep around,
your instinct should
now be to open your IDE.
I'm going to go ahead
and create a new file,
and I'm going to call it compare0.c from
my first example of comparing things.
And I'm going to go ahead and
whip up a relatively short program
that you would hope would
work right out of the box.
So I'm going to go ahead and
include the familiar cs50.h.
I'm going to go include stdio.h.
I'm going to go ahead
and do int main void.
I'm going to go ahead and in here--
let me a variable called i
using get_int from the user,
and just prompt them for i.
Let me go ahead then and prompt
the user for another get_int.
We'll call it j and get that from them.
And then let's just
compare these things.
So if i equals-equals j,
then go ahead and print out
with printf same and a new line.
Then go ahead and print out the
opposite, which is different.
So the only place I think I
could have screwed up, perhaps,
is if I did this, which is
kind of reasonable if you
come in knowing what an equal sign is.
But again, in code, we
typically need two equal signs
because that compares two values.
So I didn't make that mistake, I'm
feeling pretty good about this.
Let me save it with Command-S
or Control-S or via File,
Save; go to my prompt
and run make compare0.
Good, everything compiled.
And let me go ahead and run
compare0, Enter, and I'll type in 50,
and I'll type in 50, and
they do seem to be the same.
Let me go ahead and do that
again, let's type in 42 and 13,
and they are different.
And I should probably test a few more,
maybe some negative values, maybe some
0's, positive values
and the like, but I'm
feeling pretty good about
the correctness of this code.
All right.
So let's change this program a bit.
Let me go ahead and
create another file, which
I can do with the little green
plus or via File, New File.
I'm going to go ahead save
this one as compare1.c.
And for the moment I'm going to go
ahead and just paste in that code
from before, but I'm going
to make some changes now.
I'm going to go ahead and rename
and retype my data types as strings.
So give me a string called
s, and will prompt the user
for that using
get_string, then I'm going
to go ahead and change
this 1 to string t,
and I'm going to go
ahead and get get_string.
I, of course, need to now
compare s and t, not i and j.
And s is a common variable name
for a string. t just comes after s,
so that's pretty reasonable too, but I
should of course update that as well.
And so I think everything's
now the same logically.
I just changed my data
types and my variable names.
So I've saved this.
Let me go ahead and run make compare1.
Good, everything's correct.
Let me go ahead and do ./compare1.
Let me go ahead and type
in Brian and Veronica.
And of course, those are different.
Now let me go ahead and type in
David, let me type in David again,
and those of course are different?
Huh.
Maybe it's because I just hit
the Spacebar or something.
So let's try Erin.
Her name's a little shorter.
Hmm.
OK, let's try-- oh, what's her name?
TJ.
OK, even shorter, perfect.
TJ, can't go wrong.
Different.
I mean, what is going on?
Let's just say i, i.
Different?
So where's the logical
bug in this program?
What is it that's going on?
Yeah, what do you think?
AUDIENCE: Is it
comparing integer values?
DAVID MALAN: Is it
Well maybe.
I mean, thus far when
we've used equal-equals
we've probably used it mostly
for comparing integers,
so maybe I'm just misusing it, sure.
Other thoughts?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DAVID MALAN: Oh, that's a big word
that we'll get to in just a little bit.
But correct, correct-- but
for very similar reasons.
So something's going on
logically involving comparison,
because I'm using equal-equal, but maybe
I'm using it for the wrong data types?
I mean, it's clearly broken for strings.
So why might that actually be?
Well it turns out that
strings don't actually exist.
So a string that we know is
just a sequence of characters
or an array of characters
is not an actual data type.
int is, float is, double is,
long is, bool is, and even more
are actual data types.
String is kind of a
little white lie we've
been telling for a few weeks that's
implemented only in the CS50 library.
Now the word string is
super common in programming.
Like every programmer out there will
know what you mean when you say string.
That is not a CS50 word, but our
use of it in C is CS50-specific.
Because in that file
called cs50.h, in addition
to declaring functions like
get_string and get_int and get_float
and a bunch of other things, we
also have a special line that says,
create a data type called string.
But what does it actually do
or what does it actually mean?
Well let's go ahead and consider what
might be going on underneath the hood
here.
So if I go ahead and draw
the program that we just
ran, that program compare1
gets a string s from the user,
then gets a string t from the
user, and then compares them.
So we know from last week what
a string is, it's just an array.
So when I run that first line of
code and get a string from the user--
for instance, Brian, I'm going
to go ahead and see a B-R-I-A-N,
which we know from last week to actually
be an array of memory that might look
pictorially like this-- and this,
too, is a bit of a white lie,
there's something else.
AUDIENCE: The null.
DAVID MALAN: Yeah, the null
character, so to speak, and ul,
which we typically just write with a
backslash 0, which is just all 0 bits.
And it turns out, you might recall from
the debugger earlier, you saw this--
that's the even more cryptic way
of expressing the null character,
backslash 0.
Just different programs
display it in different ways.
So when I get_string and type in Brian,
this is what's allocated in memory.
And when I type Veronica, I
can see a V-E-R-O-N-I-C-A.
I'm going to get that
right preemptively.
Backslash 0.
That, too, is a chunk of memory,
which I'll draw like this.
1, 2, and split these up into
interval characters or bytes.
And recall from last time that these
bytes just come from my memory,
and that memory just has a bunch of
bytes in it, maybe millions or even
billions these days.
And so honestly, if you
just have that many things,
any human or computer can
certainly number them.
Like this is byte 1, 2, 3, 4.
So let's just assume for
the sake of discussion
that out of context of
my computer's hardware,
Brian just ended up at location 100, and
location 101, and 102, 103, 104, 105.
So this is the 100th
byte in my computer,
this is 105th byte in
my computer, and Brian
is using that many characters in total.
Veronica, she ended up somewhere else.
Maybe she ended up farther away just
because at location 900, 901, 902, 903,
904, 905, 906-- a lot more
memory, 907, and 908--
but you can see even more visually
now that the length of Brian's name--
strlen of Brian is what?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DAVID MALAN: I hear five and I hear six.
The length of Brian's name--
Brian, how long is your name?
AUDIENCE: Five.
DAVID MALAN: OK, it is
definitively five characters, that
is the length of Brian's
name, but you have
to appreciate that in the computer,
Brian's five-character name does indeed
take up six bytes.
So both answers are kind of correct,
but the length of the string henceforth
is always the number
of actual characters.
The amount of space it takes up is
that plus 1 for the null character.
So you can actually see why Brian's
name takes up six bytes in this picture
rather than just the actual
length, which is five.
So when you call get_string
now, and when you call
get_string and get another string--
Brian and Veronica respectively,
what is actually being handed back?
A couple weeks ago, Erin
came up and she kind of like
handed me back a string, a
student's name from the audience.
On that piece of paper we
thought was the student's name.
But it's not.
It turns out that when a
function returns a value,
it can pretty much only return
a 1 byte or maybe 2 or 4 bytes.
It can't return an arbitrary number of
bytes, like six for Brian or 1, 2, 3,
4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9-- it cannot
return 9 bytes for Veronica.
And if you even type a whole
paragraph or page of text,
it can't return all of that text,
it can only return a single value.
So to your instinct
earlier, what might actually
be getting returned by
get_string when the human has
typed in a name like Brian or Veronica?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DAVID MALAN: The memory location.
Indeed, an integer, or as
you called it, a pointer,
which we'll introduce more
formally in just a moment.
So when get_string string
returns "Brian," quote-unquote,
it's actually not returning B-R-I-A-N
backslash 0, it is just returning 100.
And when get_string returns Veronica,
it's not returning her name,
it's returning 900.
And so if you realize
that now, when you do does
s equal-equal t, what question more
mundanely are you actually asking?
Yeah.
Memory location and memory
location-- does 100 equal 900?
And obviously not.
And so that is why Brian's
name, Veronica's name,
my name, TJ's name-- every word I
typed in was of course different,
because each input was ending up
at a different location in memory.
And even if I typed the same word like
David twice, one David was going here,
one David was going somewhere
else, they were ending up
at different memory locations.
Maybe 100, maybe 900,
maybe something else,
but they were ending up in
different locations in memory.
So equal-equals does
compare values, but dammit
if it isn't comparing the wrong values.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Well what if
you use some char*s?
DAVID MALAN: Ah, so
we'll come back to that.
Let me come back to
that in just a moment.
char* is actually intricately related.
More on that in a moment.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: If you add
two integers in memory--
DAVID MALAN: Uh huh?
AUDIENCE: Wouldn't they be in
different places in memory?
So you would return--
so you need a different value.
DAVID MALAN: OK, really good question.
So wait a minute, this same logic that
I'm returning the address of something
surely applies to integers as well
or floating point values as well?
Because if I type in
the number 50 like I
did earlier, that, too, is somewhere
in memory-- like a box in memory,
and that, too, has an
address somewhere in memory,
but it turns out, for reasons that
you just alluded to, actually,
ints are returned as their values.
Chars are returned as their values.
Bools are returned as their values.
Floats are returned as their values.
Strings are different.
Strings are returned by their address.
And those addresses, it turns out,
are ultimately going to be called
char*'s, which we'll
see in just a moment.
So how do we go about then
fixing this fundamentally?
Like even if you have no idea how
to code this yet, just intuitively,
if I do actually want to delete--
if I do actually want to compare--
sorry.
OK.
If I do want to go ahead and compare
Brian and Veronica for equality,
what do I want to do intuitively?
I can't just compare their addresses.
What do I need to do?
Isolate the characters and
then do what with them?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DAVID MALAN: Good.
Yeah, good instincts.
Use a for loop, use a while loop--
any kind of looping structure.
And intuitively, compare
the first characters,
and if they're different, well then we
know we don't have to go any further.
B is not a V, so surely
these names are different.
But what about in my case?
If it was David and David, you
would compare the first two.
D and D are the same.
Compare the second two,
A and A are the same.
V and V, I and I, D and D, and
then what am I going to hit last?
Null character.
And should I keep going
beyond the null character?
No.
So this is the beauty of that
super simple design for a string.
Insofar as strings are identified by
their starting address, just the byte
at which they start,
you still need to know
how long they are, because otherwise
how do where one word begins and ends
and another word begins?
And so the simple decision we made
last week-- as did humans decades ago--
to terminate all strings with backslash
0 or all 0's is a super handy trick,
so that if I tell you
that Brian starts at 100,
you can infer that he ends where?
At byte number 105 or 104, if you will,
however you want to think about it,
because all you need
to do in linear time,
if you will, left or right, is
check-- backslash 0, backslash 0-- ah!
Backslash 0, now I know
how long Brian's name is.
So let's consider for a moment
this program called string length.
How does strlen actually work?
When you pass to strlen, a variable
containing a string, like Brian,
what is sterling probably doing?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DAVID MALAN: Exactly.
It's looking at that
null character's address
and subtracting the start
address and the end address,
figuring out what the difference
is, and actually returning
that minus 1 the total count.
And more mechanically,
we'll see in a moment,
it's probably doing exactly
the same thing I did,
which is, is this backslash 0?
Is this backslash 0?
Is this, is this, is this?
I asked that question five
times before I saw backslash 0.
strlen is just a function
some human wrote years ago
that probably just has a simple
for loop and an if condition,
and then that's it.
Because that person
understood before we even
did how strings are
actually implemented.
Any questions then?
All right, so let's
actually implement this.
Let me go ahead and into my editor
here, and make one other example here
that I'm going to call compare2.
I'm going to go ahead and do
include cs50.h and include stdio.h,
and then I'm going to do
int main void, and I'm
going to quickly now grab my code
from before where I got strings
and I compared them, but I have
to obviously fix that comparison.
So here's my code from before.
I'm going to do this the right way.
I'm going to call a function called
compare_strings passing in s and t.
Because as you proposed,
we need to do some logic.
We don't have to pass it to
a function, but we could.
We could just do a
for loop here, but I'm
going to go ahead and implement
compare_strings as follows.
If I want to write a function that
returns a yes/no answer, what data type
should it return?
A bool.
So we've not necessarily
done this yet, but you
can return a bool just like you can
int or a char or something else.
I'm going to call this
function compare_strings.
It's going to take in one string
called a and another string called b,
but I could call those anything I want.
And now what's the
easiest thing to check?
If I pass two strings, a and
b, or Brian and Veronica,
what's the easiest question you can
ask and just immediately say, nope,
these are different?
String length, right?
Like if the B-R-I-A-N is not of
the same length as Veronica's name,
we don't need to do any
logic whatsoever beyond that,
we can just quit and say false.
So let me just do that.
If the strlen of a does not equal
the strlen of b, you know what?
Let's just go ahead and return
false and get out of here.
OK, but now, if we get past
that gateway, so to speak,
that check, that question,
that Boolean expression,
now I have to compare things
character by character by character.
So I can do this in a bunch of ways,
but I like the suggestion of a for loop.
So for int i at 0, n for
efficiency-- actually,
let's do i is less than
the string length--
should I do the string length of a or b?
And it doesn't matter, right?
So let's go with a.
And frankly, had I
been smart early on, I
could have stored the value in
a variable and then reused it,
but we'll just keep going ahead for now.
Then i plus-plus, but I remember
from last time-- this is correct,
but this is not good design.
Why?
Yeah, I keep calling strlen again and
again, because remember, in a for loop,
this condition is
checked again and again
and again-- you're just
wasting your own time.
So let me go ahead and actually do this.
n or any variable equals the strlen
of a, then just compare i against n,
because now i is getting
incremented, but n is never changing.
So now let me go ahead and
implement this for loop.
So if-- how about the i-th character
of a does not equal the i-th character
of b, I can immediately conclude--
nope, these strings can't be the
same, because some letter, like a B,
is not the same as another, like a
V, or whatever letter we're actually
comparing.
And then I think that's it.
If I get through these
gauntlets of questions--
are yours lengths different?
Are your characters different?
And I still haven't said false,
what should I return by default?
Yeah.
Like if you make it through all of
those questions and all is well,
then D-A-V-I-D must indeed equal
D-A-V-I-D or whatever the user actually
typed in.
Now I'm not quite done yet.
When I've implemented a
function or a helper function
like this, because it's
helping me do my work,
what else do I have to add to the file?
Oh?
AUDIENCE: I've got a logical question.
DAVID MALAN: Sure.
AUDIENCE: In a computer, couldn't you
just type in David with a capital D
and then david with a lowercase d,
you're going to run [INAUDIBLE],,
they're not going to sync because
your first character's not
the same character.
DAVID MALAN: Correct.
So this is a feature,
not a bug at the moment.
My program at the moment
is case-sensitive.
If I type in DAVID and all
caps, that is a different string
I claim for now than
david in all lowercase.
If you want to tolerate
uppercase and lowercase,
you're going have to add more logic.
But for now that's a design
decision that I intend.
All right.
What else do I need
to add to the program?
Yeah, the prototype at top.
You can literally copy and paste--
this is the only time copy and paste is
probably a legitimate thing to do--
at the top, and then semi-colon--
don't re-implement it.
But I do need one other header file.
I'm using a function that's
not in cs50.h or in stdio.h.
String length?
Where was string length?
Yeah, string.h.
So I just need this,
include string.h, save.
Now this I think is correct.
We'll see if I eat the word in a moment.
But realize that if you're
writing this code yourself,
like this is not a natural thing to
be writing a program in office hours
or at home in your dorm and just
getting it right the first time.
This is after like 20 years of doing
this, so realize we happen to be--
and I also have a cheat
sheet right here--
we happen to be doing
this correctly often,
but realize that's not
going to be the common case.
So with that reassurance
in mind, let's see
if I have to now take all
that back. make compare2.
OK-- phew.
20 years worked out.
So now I'm going to go
ahead and ./compare2.
Let's type in Brian,
let's type in Veronica.
Those are indeed still
different hopefully.
Now let's try myself, David and David.
Phew!
Those are the same.
And to your point, David in
capitalized and David in all lowercase,
different, but that's what I expect now.
Any questions on compare2?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DAVID MALAN: OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] string
in the program and in general.
DAVID MALAN: OK.
AUDIENCE: Would that
still work [INAUDIBLE]
DAVID MALAN: If you were
to hard code the strings?
Short answer, yes,
that would still work.
If you for whatever reason did
not do this and using get_string,
but you did David, and here, for
instance, David, that would work too.
And whatever your error is, if you
can recreate it, just let us know.
AUDIENCE: It seems to be like a
string that would be increased
for a set that was [INAUDIBLE] only?
And it was having issues
in the little [INAUDIBLE]..
DAVID MALAN: I'd have to see it to
be sure, but happy to chat after.
All right, so let's see
if we can't now clean this
up just a little bit as follows.
Let me go ahead here and reveal
what it is that's actually going on.
So indeed, there is no
such thing as a string.
And indeed, as you
pointed out a moment ago,
it actually goes by a different name.
String is just a synonym
for what's called a char*.
Now what does that even mean?
So char is the same as it's always been.
It's a single character.
Star in a program written in C
could of course mean multiplication,
we have seen that.
This is another use of the star.
Whenever you see it after
a data type like char,
this means that the data type
in question is not just a char,
it's the address of a char.
So the star just means the address of
whatever the data type is to the left,
and this is, as you
pointed out earlier, what
we're going to start calling a pointer.
A pointer is, for all intents
and purposes, an address.
It's just a buzzword
to describe an address.
This data type here, char*, means I want
a variable that doesn't store a char,
it stores the address of a char.
The number 100, the number 900.
But that address is just
going to be called a pointer.
A pointer variable is a variable
that stores the address of something.
A char or even other data types as well.
So with that in mind, let me actually
quickly create compare3.c, paste this
in, and save it as compare3.c,
and let me take off, if you will,
those training wheels.
It turns out that when you
get a string with get_string,
it doesn't return a string,
per se, because again,
that word doesn't exist in C,
it actually returns a char*.
And when I call it again here and
return another string, it, too,
returns a char*.
Now technically the star
can have spaces around it.
Some people write it like this,
but the sort of right way to do it
or the default way should just be to
put the star next to the variable name
for clarity.
So I have to make a few other changes.
This should change too, because
there is no more string as of today.
I'm going to change this to a char*;
and then I also need to change it here,
char*; and then here, char*;
and that is actually it.
And honestly, the only reason we didn't
introduce this like two weeks ago
is because it just looks cryptic.
Like no one wants to program the first
time they're ever touching a keyboard
and writing code and see char* and
need to worry about what that means,
it's just a string conceptually.
But the only change I technically need
to make to take those training wheels
off is just change all mentions
of string as data types to char*.
And that just means
that you know what-- a?
Yes it's a string, but more technically
it's the address of a string.
Or more precisely, it is the address
of the first byte of the string,
like 100 for Brian or 900 for
Veronica, and I'm not even
going to tell you where the string
ends because you, the programmer,
can figure that out by calling
strlen or just by using a loop
and figuring out where that
backslash 0 actually is.
So that is enough information
to pass it around.
So if go ahead now and
compile this, make compare3,
and then I go ahead and do ./compare3,
let's go ahead and type in Brian
and Veronica, those are
indeed still different.
Now let me go ahead and type in David
and David, those are in fact the same.
So the training wheels are off,
there is no such thing as string,
henceforth it's a char*.
Let's go ahead and take a quick
break here for five minutes,
and we'll come back and dive in more.
All right.
So we are back, and let's go
ahead and simplify this now,
as our tendency has been.
It's kind of a bunch
of code, but I think
we can make this a little tighter.
But rather than type
this one out manually,
let me go ahead and just open
one of our pre-made examples
from today, which is all in the
course's website, called compare4.
And you'll see in compare4, that's it.
I only have a main function this time.
I've gotten rid of my compare_strings
function because you know what?
I seem to be using something instead.
What function did I apparently deploy?
Yeah, S-T-R-C-M-P, or
someone with pronounce it,
just str compare or strcmp.
So this, like strlen,
also succinctly named,
is just a function
that's actually declared
in one of our familiar
libraries up top, string.h,
and it turns out if you look
in the man page, so to speak,
by typing man strcmp, or if you
go to CS50 reference and actually
look at the less comfortable
description of the function there,
this is just a function
whose sole purpose in life
is to compare strings for you.
But it's a little different
in behavior because it's
a little fancier than
the one I just wrote.
Let me zoom in on this, and
you'll see that line 14 here, I'm
not quite treating it in the same way.
My logic is ever so slightly different.
What am I actually checking for in
my Boolean expression this time?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DAVID MALAN: Yeah,
which is a little weird.
I'm checking explicitly-- if strcmp's
return value equal-equal to 0.
Before I just said, if
compare_strings s comma
t, because I was expecting back a bool--
true or false. strcmp, kind of weird,
acts the opposite way.
It turns out that strcmp
doesn't return true and false.
If you read its documentation, it
returns 0 if the strings are equal,
but super conveniently, it
returns a positive value
if s is supposed to come before
t, and it returns a negative value
if s is supposed to come
after t alphabetically.
So it turns out that you can use strcmp
not just to compare for equality,
but inequality--
less than or equal--
less than or greater than,
so to speak, alphabetically,
or in ASCII order, so to speak.
It will actually compare character
by character the ASCII values,
and that will make sure
that B comes after A,
and C comes after B, and so forth.
So you can actually use strcmp
to like sort a dictionary,
or to sort the contacts in your
iPhone or your Android phone.
So long story short, this
is a function we can use,
we don't have to reinvent this
wheel, and thus, we have no more code
even after this.
We just have to use it correctly,
and there, the documentation
is your friend.
So if I run this program it's
going to work exactly the same way,
but let me go ahead and
point out some flaws.
It turns out all this time, I've been
a little lazy with my error checking--
checking for errors.
There's a whole bunch of things
that can go wrong in week 1 of CS50
that we just kind of turn a blind
eye to, because it would just
bloat our code, make it longer and sort
of less interesting and fun to write
and less comprehensible.
But today, now that we know
what's actually going on,
we can begin to ask some
additional questions
and make our code
stronger, more robust so
that nothing does, in fact, go wrong.
Turns out, if you read the documentation
for get_string in the man page
or in CS50 reference,
turns out get_string
does return a string-- uh, not really.
It returns the address of a string.
Uh, not really.
It returns the address of the first
byte of a string, technically.
But if something goes wrong, it returns
a special character called null.
Not to be confused with NUL, it
returns a special address called null--
left hand wasn't talking
to right hand decades ago.
So null, N-U-L-L, just means the address
0, which nothing should ever live at.
It's just a bogus, invalid address.
Insofar as get_string returns the
address of a string in memory,
like 100 for Brian or 900 for
Veronica, if get_string ever
runs into a problem and just something
goes wrong with the computer,
if it ever returns 0,
specifically 0, a.k.a.
null-- N-U-L-L, then you can detect
that something has gone wrong.
So to do that, and it's going
to get a little tedious,
but it's nonetheless
the right thing to do,
I need to be a little more defensive.
If s equals-equals null, otherwise
known as 0, otherwise known as 0x0,
but I'll write it
conventionally like this,
I'm going to go ahead and
return 1 as my exit code.
If t equals-equals null, I'm going to
go ahead and return 1 as my exit code,
or I could return 2 or 3--
I just need to return some
value to signal to the computer
that something went wrong,
but by default we'll
just return 1 whenever something
goes wrong, but if all went well,
I'm going to go ahead and return 0.
So recall again from last week, and
we didn't spend a huge amount of time
on this--
main itself can return values.
By default, ever since week 1,
if you don't return anything,
main is automatically and secretly
returning 0 for you because 0 is good.
The reason for 0 is because there's
only one 0 in the world, obviously,
but there is an infinite
number to the left
and there's an infinite number of
the right, negative and positive.
That's great, because as you've already
experienced in the past few weeks,
it feels like there's an infinite number
of things that can go wrong when you're
writing even the shortest of programs.
So that means we have a lot of
numbers we can assign to error codes,
so to speak.
Now I don't really care
what the error codes are,
so I'm just going to adopt the
human convention at the moment--
if anything goes wrong,
returns anything other than 0.
And so I'm going to return 1 up here,
but if nothing goes wrong, return 0.
The point here is that by adding
these three lines here and these three
lines here, I'm going
to avoid what's called
a segmentation fault or
segfault. Did any of you
encounter this cryptic error?
OK.
So a decent number of you, and if you
probably had no idea what that means,
but starting today you will a bit
more, and in the weeks to come,
you'll understand even more.
Segmentation fault means you
touched memory you should not have.
Or something went wrong
and you did not detect it.
It's kind of a catch-all phrase
for memory-related problems.
This helps ward off
those kinds of errors.
It's not the only way,
but it's one such way.
So starting today with problems
set programs and anything
you write in the course, you
always want to be thinking about,
even if you go back and add
it later, could this go wrong?
Could this go wrong?
And just add some
additional ifs and else-ifs
and handle those situations so that
your program doesn't just crash on you
or segfault or surprise someone
who's actually using it.
All right, let's take a
look at one final example,
because frankly this
is a little tedious.
I'm going to go ahead and open up--
and this file can be
found in compare5.c.
Let me go ahead and save this
so that we have it-- compare5.c.
I'm going to make one
final comparison example.
I'm going to save this as compare6.c.
Turns out that humans
like their succinctness.
And null, because it is
technically the 0 address,
you can actually be a little clever.
If not s and if not t is a sufficient
way to express those same things.
Because what does the bang do?
The exclamation point
in code if you recall?
It inverts something.
So like if this is saying, if s is not
0, a.k.a., if s not null, or rather--
if-- now I'm getting confused.
Yes.
If I had just said, if s,
then it's a valid address
and I should go on with my business.
But if it's not s or
if s is null, I want
to go ahead and return 1 because
there's an error, and down here too.
So any time you're checking
whether something equals null,
you can make it more succinct by
just saying if not s; if it's null,
return 1.
If it's null, return 1.
It's just syntactic shorthand.
Phew!
I had to think about that one.
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: Why does [INAUDIBLE]
will store some [INAUDIBLE]
DAVID MALAN: Correct.
You are storing an address,
but if that address is 0.
Saying if it's not 0, 0 is like
false, so not false means true,
and so it has the effect
of inverting the logic.
That's all.
Anytime you use a bang or exclamation
point, it changes a 0 to non-0--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE], but even--
I don't understand why [INAUDIBLE]
implies that it's [INAUDIBLE]..
DAVID MALAN: So you can
think about it this way.
If s-- previously we had this.
If s equals-equals null is like
saying if s literally equals 0.
And you can kind of think
of that informally as
if s doesn't have a valid pointer--
0 is not a valid point or it's
not a valid address by definition.
100 is valid, 900 is valid, 0 is not
valid just by a human convention.
So this is like saying, if s does
not have a value, that's valid.
So the way to succinctly
say that, if not s,
and it's just shorthand for that
is another way to think about it.
All right, so let's take a look
at a very different program,
but that reveals the same
kind of issue as follows.
I'm going to go ahead and
open up an example called
copy0, whose purpose in life
hopefully is to copy a string.
So notice that in my
program here, which I
wrote in advance, I'm getting a
string from the user on line 11,
and I'm storing it in a string called s.
I could change this to char*
now, but we know what it is.
And I'm going to go ahead and copy
the string's address from s into t.
And then I'm going to say, if the
length of t is greater than 0,
then go ahead and just
capitalize the first character.
So it's a little cryptic,
but you might have
done something kind of like this
with Caesar and with recent string
manipulation.
This is just making sure, do
I have at least one character?
And if so, first character is
t bracket 0, as you recall.
toupper is a function in
ctype.h from last week
that just capitalizes this letter.
So this one line of code, 19,
just capitalizes the first letter
in t, that's it.
And then at the very end we just print
out what s is and print out what t is.
That's all.
So this program just copies s into
t, capitalizes t, and that's it.
So let me go ahead and make copy0.
This is in our code from today.
So I'm going to do cd sc3, because I
already wrote it in that directory.
make copy0.
Went well. ./copy0.
Let's go ahead and type
in tj again in lowercase.
Enter.
Huh.
TJ, TJ-- both are capitalized.
All right, maybe it's just
a weird thing with initials.
So let's just do
Veronica, all lowercase.
Huh, that's definitely capital.
Let's do even more obvious
difference, Brian where
the B's really going to look different.
Yet I'm only capitalizing t.
Well let's consider what's
actually going on here.
In this case, when I'm getting a string
from the user, s and t, and I type in,
for instance, brian in all lowercase,
backslash 0, this, of course,
is just an array underneath the hood.
This is taking up six bytes here.
And when I store in s, s is a string.
So you know what?
We didn't do this before.
Let me actually create a variable, a
chunk of memory for s and call it s.
And suppose Brian is just
where he was before--
100, 101, 102, 103, 104, and 105.
So if I do s equals get_string
and get_string returns Brian,
what do I write in the box called s?
Yeah, just 100, right?
This is all that's been
going on all this time
even though we didn't talk
about it at this level.
And actually, it turns out-- pointer
actually can be used pictorially.
If you actually prefer to think
about a pointer as being an address
or like kind of a map that leads
you somewhere, another way a human
would typically draw a
pointer-- because honestly,
who really cares that
Brian is at address 100?
Like that is way too low
level, that's week 0 stuff.
He's just pointing there.
So s is a pointer to
that chunk of memory.
It happens to be 100, whatever, the
arrow is how you would literally
point at the chunk of memory if you
were drawing this on some notes.
So that, too, is correct.
So the problem arises here
with that line of code.
When I actually try to copy s and store
in t, think about what's going on.
The right-hand side is just s's
value, which happens to be 100.
The left-hand side is just
saying, hey computer, give me
another variable, first
string, and call it t.
So that's like saying, hey, computer,
give me another chunk of memory,
call it t, and then store s in it.
But what does it mean to store s?
Well what is s's value
at this point in time?
It's the pointer to Brian,
or it's technically--
I'll write both just for thoroughness--
it's literally the number 100.
So if you do t equals s, that is
like saying put 100 there too,
and pictorially that's like saying this.
So at this point in the
story, when I copy s into t,
the computer took me literally.
It did copy s into t, but what is s?
It's just the address.
It is not B-R-I-A-N backslash
0, it's just the address.
So when I then say, t
bracket 0 gets toupper--
so let's look at this line of code.
The one line of code
here that's highlighted,
when I say go to the 0th
character of t and store
the uppercase version of that same
character, you just follow the arrows.
If you ever played chutes
and ladders as a kid,
you just kind of follow the
arrow, see where you end up.
t bracket 0 is this location
here, because again,
if this is a chunk of memory,
per last week it's an array,
so you can also think of this as
being bracket 0, this is bracket 1,
this is bracket 2, and so forth.
So it's just an array.
So t bracket 0 is lowercase
b, and toupper of lowercase b,
of course, changes this
little b to a B. But now
both s and t are still pointing
at the same chunk of memory,
so of course s and t are both
going to be Bryan capitalized,
or TJ too in my first example.
Any questions then on what we
just did and why that happens?
All right, so intuitively
what's the fix?
Doesn't matter if you've
no idea how to code it,
like what do we have to do to
fundamentally copy a string, not
an address?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DAVID MALAN: Create a new what?
AUDIENCE: Basically
create the [INAUDIBLE]..
DAVID MALAN: Yeah.
Create the same string
in a new chunk of memory.
What I really need to do
is allocate or give myself
a bunch of more memory
that's just as big as Brian,
including his backslash 0.
And then logically I just need to
copy every character into that.
So if I go back to my original
when it was a lowercase b,
I need to make a copy logically by
using a for loop or a while loop
or whatever you prefer--
B-R-I-A-N backslash 0, so that when I
copy the string and then store it in t,
It's not actually copying literally s.
And let's suppose that he ends up
at location 300 just arbitrarily--
just making up easy numbers.
t now stores 300, points here.
So when I execute this line in this
version of the story, t bracket 0
gets toupper, what am I actually doing?
I'm following a
different arrow this time
because I gave myself a different chunk
of memory, capitalizing this Brian,
thereby hopefully fixing the
bug, albeit verbally only.
So how do we do this in code?
We need to do exactly that.
We need to give ourself
some more memory,
so let's introduce one other
feature of C. In copy1.c,
we see the solution to this problem.
Notice at the top I'm doing things a
little lower level-- oop, surprise.
Notice in this version
of the code, copy1.c,
see I've started off almost the
same, but just to be super clear,
I'm just using char*.
I don't want any magic,
so there's no string,
there's no training wheels here.
But this logically is the
exact same as before--
plus the error-checking.
This line is new.
And it looks a little funky,
but let's see what's going on.
And this line of code
here, what am I doing?
The left-hand side, that's shorter,
let's start with the easier one.
Char* t, just in layman's terms,
what does that expression do? char*?
Hey computer, do what?
What's that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DAVID MALAN: Not quite yet.
Different formulation.
Hey computer, give me--
not quite.
Be more precise?
AUDIENCE: An array?
DAVID MALAN: Not quite
an array, just this part.
So let me hide all this.
If the star wasn't there--
I can't really do this very well.
So this-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] character?
DAVID MALAN: Good, I'll take that.
So hey computer, give me
a pointer to a character.
Or even more low level,
hey computer, give me
a chunk of memory in which I can
store the address of a character.
I mean, it is that mundane.
Draw a box on the screen,
call it s-- or rather,
call it t, but just give me
space for a pointer, as you said.
So that's all that's doing.
It's drawing a box on the screen and
calling it t, and it's currently empty.
Now let's look at the scarier
part on the right-hand side.
malloc, new function today.
Stands for memory allocates.
It's very cryptic-sounding, but it
just means give me a chunk of memory.
It says exactly what you
said in functional terms.
Then it just needs you
to answer one question--
OK, how much memory do you want?
How many bytes do you want?
And now maybe the math, even though
cryptic at first glance, makes sense.
Get the string length of s,
add 1, and then multiply it
by the size of a character.
And we've not seen this before.
sizeof literally does that.
It tells you how many bytes is a char.
Happens to be 1, and in
fact, that's defined.
So if we simplify this in C,
the char is always 1 byte,
so this is equivalent to
just multiplying by 1.
And obviously mathematically
that's a waste of time,
so we can whittle this
down to be even simpler.
I was just being thorough.
So now, hey computer, allocate
me this many bytes of memory.
Why is it plus 1?
AUDIENCE: You need the null character.
DAVID MALAN: I need that null character.
Brian is 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 as he said, but
I need the sixth for his null character,
and I just know that's
going to be there.
So at this point in the
story, what has happened?
All that malloc does is it
gives me this box of memory
containing room for as many
bytes are in Brian's name.
But it doesn't fill them just yet.
Now I need to logically fill those
bytes with Brian's actual name.
So if we scroll down
to my for loop here,
we can actually copy the
string into that space.
And it's a little long, the
expression, but nothing new here.
Initialize i to 0, n to the length
of s, i is less than or equal to n--
we'll come back to that, i++.
So it's just a pretty standard for loop.
Then copy the i-th character of
s into the i-th character of t.
The only thing that's making me a little
nervous honestly is this thing here.
Like I feel like every time
we do less than or equal to,
we create a bug like last week.
But this is correct, why?
Why do I want to go up to and
through the length of this?
AUDIENCE: Is it the null
character that adds--
DAVID MALAN: Exactly.
Because of the null character.
I actually don't want to stop at the
strlen of s, so I could change this.
If you're just more comfortable
using less than, because you just
got your mind wrapped around why we do
that in the first place, that's fine,
we just need to do this instead.
So this is mathematically-- if you
go to strlen plus 1, the same thing
as not doing that math but
just going one step further.
Just whatever you want to
think about it is fine.
However you want to
OK, and then lastly, just a
quick check, is the length
of t at least one or more characters?
Because otherwise there's
nothing to capitalize, and if so,
go ahead and do it.
So if I now run this example,
make-- oop, let me save it.
make copy1, that compiled.
./copy1, now let's type in tj,
tj in lowercase comes back,
but now t is capitalized.
And let's go ahead and do Brian's name
in all lowercase, only one of them
is now capitalized.
So does that make sense
what's now happened?
All right.
So where can we go with this?
Well it turns out-- let me
open up one final example here,
because honestly, that's
incredibly tedious,
and no one's ever going to
want to copy strings if you
have to go through all of that work.
Turns out that store copy exists.
So when in doubt, check the man page.
When in doubt, check CS50 reference.
Does the function
exist somewhere related
to some keywords you have in mind?
Like string copy, see
if something comes back.
And indeed, we've had strlen, we've
had strcmp, we now have strcpy,
and if you read the documentation, this
is deliberately reversed like this.
The destination is this variable,
the source or the origin string
is this one, and it copies
from one end to the other,
and then I don't need that for loop.
It just saves me a few lines of code.
All right.
So let's take off one other detail here.
Oh, and you'll notice, actually,
let me make one fix, one fix here.
It turns out that what I'm
doing here is a little lazy.
It turns out that malloc
does have an opposite.
So anytime you allocate
memory, technically
you should also be freeing that memory.
And so C allows you to ask the computer
for as much memory as you want,
but if you never give it back, have you
ever experienced on your own Mac or PC,
like after your computer's
been running a while
or using some new or bloated
program like a browser,
it gets slower and slower and slower?
And in the worse case it just
freezes or hangs or something?
It is quite possible that that
program simply-- was made by humans,
of course--
just has a memory leak.
So some human wrote one or more
lines of code that uses malloc
or some equivalent in another language
that just kept allocating memory
for the user's input.
You're visiting one web
page, two web pages,
that requires memory
whatever the program is.
And if that human never calls the
opposite of allocate-- deallocate,
otherwise known as free, you're
never giving the memory back
to the operating system.
So it gets slower and slower because
it's running lower and lower and lower
on memory, and it might have
to move some things around
to make room for things, that's
what's called a memory leak.
And so indeed, in this program, I should
actually improve this a little bit.
If I go back into this version
here and line 18, recall,
I allocated this memory
just to make my copy,
the very last thing I should
actually do in this program
is this line here-- free.
You don't have to tell the computer
how many bytes you want to free,
it will remember for you so long as
you're just pass in the pointer--
the variable that's storing the
address of the chunk of memory
that you allocated.
All right.
So let's now see why we've
been using get_string,
since it's not just to
kind of simplify the code,
it's also to defend against
some very easy problems.
Here is a program called scanf0--
scanned formatted text, another
arcane-sounding function,
but it's pretty straightforward.
This program simply gets in
from the user using scanf.
Up until now for the past three
weeks, you've used get_int.
So this is an alternative
to get_int that you could
have started using a few weeks ago.
Give me an int called x,
print out x colon whatever--
that's just the prompt to the user.
scanf %i, &x;, whatever that is, and
then print out x's value using %i.
So what's going on here?
Now today we can actually start to wrap
our minds around what get_int actually
does.
This is effectively get_int.
If you actually look at the source code
for get_int, it's a little fancier.
But in essence, what get_int does
is it declares a variable called x,
and it doesn't put anything
there, because that's
supposed to come from you, the human.
It then prompts you for whatever
string you pass to get_int,
so those are the first two lines.
And this is the only weird-looking one.
Scanf is like the opposite of printf.
You still use a formatted
string-- %s, %i, %f or whatever,
but you're not going to output this,
you're going to input this from
the human's keyboard.
And %x is the opposite of--
is the special symbol in C that says,
go ahead and get me the address of x.
So don't pass in x, give
me the address of x.
Now why is that?
We'll see, but this is the way
where you can tell the computer,
I've made a variable for you
called x, here is where it is.
It's a treasure map that leads you
to x, go put a value here for me.
And so the end result is that we
do, in fact, end up getting an int.
If I do make scanf0, and then
./scanf0, I'll type in 42, all right?
It's not an interesting program,
it just spits back out what I got,
but that's literally all
that get_int, of course,
is doing if you then
print out the value.
So if I stipulate this is correct, this
is how you get an int from the user,
but honestly, the reason we don't do
this in week 1 of the course is like,
my God, we just took the fun out of even
getting a simple number from the user
by using these lines of
code and whoever knows
what this symbol is-- we don't
want you to think about that,
we want you to just get an int.
But today those training
wheels are off, but we're
going to run into a problem super fast.
Let's try the same thing with a string.
If I were to do this, you would
think that the result is the same.
Or let's just do it as char*.
But there's going to be one tweak.
If I go ahead and give myself space
for the address of a character,
I don't need to use the
ampersand now, because scanf
does need to be told where
the chunk of memory is,
but it's already an address, so
I don't need the ampersand here.
Recall earlier, I declared
int x, which was just an int.
%x gets the address of that int.
Here, I'm saying from the get-go,
get me the address of a char.
I don't need the ampersand cause I
already have the address of a char
by definition of that star symbol.
So what's going on here?
Let me see now.
If I run scanf1, what happens?
So make scanf1 and--
oh, let's see.
Here's a warning I'm getting.
Variable s is uninitialized
when used here.
All right, that's fine.
It wants me to initialize it because
this is a very common mistake.
Those of you who alluded
to segmentation faults
earlier might have encountered
something similar in spirit to this.
So that squelched that error.
Let me go ahead and run scanf1.
All right, here we go, TJ.
Hmm.
That is not your name, but OK.
It didn't crash at least,
it's just a little weird.
David.
Null, OK, that's a little weird.
Let's go ahead and do this again.
Let's type in a really long name.
Enter.
Dammit, that didn't work.
So let's try an even longer name.
I'm hitting paste a lot.
OK-- dammit.
Too many times.
Command not found, that's
definitely not a command.
Wow, OK.
Well that's interesting.
Oh, there it is.
Null, same thing.
OK, so what's actually going on?
Well null, which is all
lowercase here, which
is this kind of an aesthetic
thing, well it's not working.
It's not working.
Well what am I actually doing?
In that first line of code, when
I say give me s to be a char*,
otherwise known as a string, all
that's doing is allocating this.
And it's technically
the size of a pointer.
A pointer, we never mentioned
this before, but now we can.
Turns out it is 64 bits or 8 bytes.
8 bits is 1 bytes, so a pointer is
by definition on many computers these
days-- most of your Macs, most of your
PCs, the IDE, the Sandbox, the Lab--
is 64-bit.
So that just means there's 64 bits
here, but we initialized it to null,
so that just means there's
64 0's here, dot-dot-dot.
But when I get a string
using scanf, what
I'm telling the computer to do
with this line of code here,
notice, is hey computer, go to that
address and put a string there.
So what's actually happening?
It turns out that there's just
not enough room to type in TJ.
There's not enough room--
that's a bit of a white lie,
because we could fit you in 64 bits,
but there's not enough room to type in
the long sentence or paragraph of text
I did, right?
What did we not do?
We didn't allocate any space over here.
All we allocated space
for was the address.
And so every time I use scanf saying,
get me a string and put it here,
there's nowhere to put it.
And so the value just very
defensively says, no, like no,
cannot store this anywhere for you.
So I actually need to be a
little smarter about this.
I actually need to get myself some space
so that I can actually store something
in the right place.
Let's do that.
Let me go ahead and
create a new program.
I'm going to go ahead
and call this scanf2.
We need a little secret
code to remind me of that.
Oh, wrong file name.
So I'm gone ahead and
create a file called scanf2.
scanf2.c.
And I'm going to quickly recreate
this stdio.h, int main void,
and then down here I'm going to
go ahead and-- you know what?
Instead of a string s, which
I know today to be a char* s,
what is this string really?
Well you said it earlier.
What is this string?
It's an array of characters.
Let me take you literally.
Just give me an array of
let's say five characters.
The D-A-V-I-D, or one more, that's
fine, just enough for my backslash 0.
Let me just create a
string-- really low level,
but this time give myself
the chunk of memory.
I don't want just the
address of a character,
I want the actual characters themselves.
Let me go ahead and just prompt
the human for their string with s,
just like before.
Then let me call scanf and get a string
from the user using %s and then pass
in s.
And here's a little trick.
It turns out that because a
string is really just an array,
but a string is also just a
pointer, you can actually treat
an array as though it is a pointer--
an address.
And so even though this is
a char* array, this is OK.
This is the equivalent in this context
to being just the address of a string.
Because strings are arrays, arrays
can be treated as pointers as of now.
And then let me go ahead and just
print out whatever the human typed in.
S is actually this.
Pass in s;, save.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE] char*?
DAVID MALAN: At this point it
would be redundant to do char*,
because I literally want for
this story six characters.
I want space, rather,
for six characters.
So this is kind of week 2 stuff
now, there's no pointers involved.
But again, just showing the
equivalence of these ideas for now.
So if I now go into this, and this is
in my other directory at the moment,
make scanf2, Enter, ./scanf2,
s is going to type in--
I'll type in my name, I know I can
fit that, we're back in business.
Like now it's working because I didn't
just create the address for a string,
I created the space for the string.
But let me get a little dangerous--
David Malan?
OK, that kind of worked out OK.
David Malan or some
really long other name?
OK, that worked out too.
Let me go ahead and run it again.
Let me try that really long
string again, see what happens.
I know this didn't work
very well last time.
All right, done.
Ooh, OK.
So now I'm in the club of those of
you who have had segmentation faults.
So let's understand
what's going on here.
Segmentation fault a
moment ago I claimed
was touching a segment, a chunk
of memory that's not your own.
So just happened?
Well with this simple program, I
told the computer, hey computer,
give me room for six
characters, give me six bytes.
With the scanf line, I'm telling
the computer, put the following user
input at that location, in
that array of characters.
D-A-V-I-D backslash 0 fit.
David Malan didn't really, but
it didn't seem to be a huge deal.
David Malan or some really long other
name, also didn't crash the computer.
But that's because unbeknownst to us,
usually when you ask for six bytes,
the computer is kind of sort of--
it's giving you a few extras.
It's not safe to use them,
but it gives you enough
that you're not going to necessarily
see a problem like a segmentation fault.
But it only allocates a
few extra bytes typically,
so if you really keep pasting in
long, long, long, long lines of text,
eventually you're going
exceed not only those six
bytes, but well past the special--
the secret bytes that you got back
that you shouldn't be using anyway,
and that point the computer
just gives up and says,
you are touching memory
you shouldn't, a.k.a.
segmentation fault.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] if
the computer gives you
a few extra bytes, then why isn't
it printing any of the other stuff?
After you said [INAUDIBLE]
it just printed David.
DAVID MALAN: Really good question.
So even though I'm getting
these sort of extra bytes,
why am I not seeing
them after D-A-V-I-D?
I'm probably getting lucky.
Long story short, when
you first run a program,
much of the memory that your program
has access to is by default initialized
to 0's.
0 is the same thing as backslash
0, and so I'm getting lucky.
When I had D-A-V-I-D and then
excess space in that array,
a lot of them are
initialized as 0's already,
and the string is getting
secretly terminated for me.
Or the better answer is,
it's undefined behavior.
Like you should not touch
memory that is not your own.
What happens after that
is your risk alone.
But that's a conjecture as
to why that's happening.
All right, so what is the
fundamental feature than get_int
is providing for us?
All of this time get_int
has actually been dealing
with all of this headache for us.
I mean honestly, even I'm getting
bored like thinking about, talking
about how you just get a
damn string from the user,
because you need to figure out,
well how many bytes do you need?
And what if the human types in one
more bite than you were expecting?
Then you need to do a
switcheroo and get more memory.
get_string is doing all
of this headache for us.
And that's not to say you
need to use it forever,
there are indeed training
wheels, but that's
just because when you're using C
or a lot of programming languages,
the computer will only do
what you tell it to do.
And it turns out that even
asking the user for input,
if you don't know how many
characters he or she is
going to type in from the
get-go, you have to deal with it.
And so underneath the hood-- and you're
welcome to take a look at the source
code for CS50's library, which I'll
post on the home page later today,
it turns out that with the way we're
doing get_string is taking baby steps.
We literally like get
one character at a time
from the user, kind of
building the road as we go.
And if we don't have enough
space, we ask the computer,
give me some more bytes
so I can get more bytes,
and we just get one
character at a time so
that we can handle the user maliciously
or accidentally typing in way
more input than we actually expect.
So let's contextualize all of this then.
Recall that we've been drawing these
pictures the past couple of weeks.
Let's just make this super clear
as to what's been going on.
This is a memory module in a computer.
It's just a green board, it's
way blown out of scale here,
it's easily like yea big inside of
your Mac or PC laptop or desktop,
though can vary in size.
One of these black chips is
the actual memory or the bytes
to which we've been referring.
And if we zoom in on that,
recall that I proposed last week
that you can just think about
this as like a grid, an array.
And it doesn't have to be rectangular,
this is just an artist's rendition,
but each of those squares
represents, we claimed, a byte.
And each of those bytes can be
addressed in some way with a number.
And that number is just its location,
otherwise known as an address.
We can actually see this,
it turns out, as follows.
Let me go ahead and open
up this example here.
Or actually, you know, let's
just write this one from scratch.
Let me write a program
called addresses.c.
And that's going to use our old friends,
the CS50 library and stdio.h and int
main void.
And let me go ahead and just do this.
I'm going to go ahead and get a string--
you know what?
No more string. char* from the user,
get_string, ask the user for s.
And we get another string, a.k.a.
char*, get_string, call
it t from the user.
And then, I want to print out not the
strings, which I used to do like this,
printing out s.
I want to print out the pointer that
s really is, that is the address.
Turns out %p for pointer will print out
not the string at that memory location,
it will print the actual
memory location for you of s.
And I can do the same thing here,
%p, backslash 0, paste in t.
And just so I know which is
which, let me just prefix it
with some text-- s colon and t colon.
Let me go ahead now down
here and do make addresses.
Oh, I messed up, missed a semi-colon.
Let me do this again.
make addresses.
And get rid of this.
That compiled OK,
./addresses, and here we go.
Let's type in-- let's do Brian
and Veronica like before.
Enter.
And this is a little funky, but
it turns out the IDE in your Macs
and your PCs have a lot of memory.
So this is the address.
It's not quite as small as 100,
it's not quite as small as 900.
It's actually kind of big.
It's 2331010 with this weird 0x.
Well it turns out, this is
just a human convention.
In week 0 we talked about
decimal and all of us
grew up with decimal,
10 digits from 0 to 9.
Talked a little bit
about binary 0's and 1's.
Turns out there's an infinite
number of base systems--
decimal/dec, binary/bi are just two of
those infinite number of possibilities.
Turns out there's another one that's
super common called hexadecimal.
Hexa meaning 16 in this case.
So base-16 actually has 16
letters in its alphabet.
0, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7,
8, 9, a, b, c, d, e, f.
So it turns out that base systems that
need to count higher than 10 characters
just start using letters of
the alphabet by convention.
Humans just decided this.
So we're getting just
numbers in this case,
but if these addresses
were even bigger, we
might actually see some alphabetical
letters between a and f there.
And frankly I don't know
what address this is,
but Google's usually
pretty good at this stuff,
so let me actually open
up another browser window.
So Google is your friend
when it comes to this stuff,
so let me actually open
up another browser window.
So Google is your friend
when it comes to this stuff,
or any number of calculators.
0x2331010 in decimal please.
And Google has translated that.
So Brian, I-- kind of
under a bit earlier.
He is not at address
location 0, he's actually
in the 36 millionth byte
inside of my computer
right now, location 36,900,880.
So a little higher address than 100.
And then Veronica, if you really
want to get into the weeds here,
we can say "in decimal," let
Google translate that for us.
She's at location 36,900,944.
Why?
Who cares?
The computer is managing all of this
for us, but when get_string used malloc,
these are literally the numbers
that were being returned saying,
you may use this chunk of memory.
And why did humans use hexadecimal?
Like it's just slightly more compact
to say 0x2331050, then 36900944--
like you just save a few digits,
so it's just conventional.
That's all, there's no magic there.
But, recall earlier.
Do you recall that when I had
the debugger open earlier,
you saw next to my name variable
a value that was cryptically 0x0?
Then there was another
value that I don't recall--
0x-something?
That was just the numeric address
of my name in hexadecimal.
And 0x0 is just the technical
address being used by null.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You said the address printed
out was [INAUDIBLE] x of the variable s
and--
DAVID MALAN: Sorry,
could you say that again?
AUDIENCE: You said the address
printed out on the screen was an x,
but x is [INAUDIBLE]
DAVID MALAN: Ah, I should've clarified.
0x, humans years ago decided
anytime you see anything
with 0x, that means whatever
comes next is hexadecimal.
Just the convention.
It's also common too if it starts with
a 0, it's an octal, which is base-8.
If you see a lowercase b at
the end, it means binary.
So humans have just
come up with symbology
as to kind of communicate
this to readers, that's all.
Not part of the value.
So turns out that we can
actually do this math ourselves.
And we won't really get
into the weeds of this
because it's not a
particularly useful life
skill, to be able to convert
to various base systems,
but let's just do one example
so that we've seen it.
Just to make clear that
there's no magic here,
it's just a different way of thinking
about numbers versus grade school.
So if back in the day we
had three decimal numbers--
255, 216, and then another
255, if we rewound to week 0,
we could go through the math
of converting that to binary.
And even if it might take you a little
while, this is the binary equivalent.
And frankly, the first
and last are kind of easy.
255 is kind of a special value
because with 8 bits, all of which
are 1, that's what gives you 255.
So the only hard one is actually this.
But who cares about the math today.
We know from weeks ago that we
can do this if we really tried.
But notice that bytes are eight bits,
and of course, eight is a pair of four,
if you will.
Well what's really nice about
hexadecimal is that it starts at 0
and ends at f.
And that's 0, 1, 2,
3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9--
wait-- yes, that's 10.
OK.
And then a, b, c, d, e, f.
I just held up 16 fingers in
total, hence, hexadecimal.
What's nice about base-16 is that how
many bits do I need to count from 0 up
to--
one, two, three, four--
15?
Just 4, right?
So if I have all 0 bits, that's 0.
And if I have 4 1-bits, that's--
let's see.
This is an 8 plus 4 plus
2 plus 1 gives me 15.
So long story short, hexadecimal's
super convenient because 0 through f
maps wonderfully cleanly to 4 bits.
So it's just a nice way of thinking
about the world not in units of 8
but in 4 instead.
So all I did here was I
took my values and I just
added a little bit of
whitespace to make clear
that 8 bits is like a pair of 4 bits.
It turns out now that 1 1 1 1 is f
for the reasons I enumerated earlier.
All 1's is f, otherwise known as 15.
All 1's is again f,
otherwise known as 15.
If we did the math, 1 1 0 1 is d, 1 0
0 0 is 8, and then all 1's is f and f.
So long story short, there is
a way to convert from decimal
to binary, to hexadecimal, to
any number of other base systems.
It all just boils down to
what digits you care about.
And the way you write this,
to your question earlier,
is by human convention.
Not just FFDAFF, but
0xFF0xD80xFF just because.
Then it's clear to the user what it is.
So a little levity now.
I'm sorry to do this to you,
but now you will all hopefully
understand this famous comic.
OK, welcome to that club of people
who understand things like this.
So let's now stumble upon
just one last problem,
and we'll take it home by
putting into the context
a very sexy field of forensics
where all of these building blocks
will come into play.
But first let's start with a problem.
Suppose I want to implement a function
here called swap whose purpose in life
is just to swap two values, a and b.
I just want to do a switcheroo.
Let's first do this with a sort
of mid-lecture snack for at least
one person.
Would anyone be up for--
OK, that was fast.
Volunteering, come on up.
What's your name?
Kelly, all right.
Thank you for volunteering so suddenly.
Kelly, David, nice to meet you.
OK, so very simple task at hand.
I have here two empty cups,
and we have some orange juice.
OK, put this in here.
And we've got some milk over here.
That should stand out,
very different colors.
OK, I would just like you, Kelly,
if you could, swap those two values.
Orange goes into milk, milk
goes into orange please.
That is cheating, OK?
No, I mean literally the cups.
I put them in the wrong
cup, I prefer my milk
in the other cup and my orange
juice in the other cup, I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: Pour it back in.
DAVID MALAN: No, that is
not available to you, OK?
[LAUGHTER]
OK, so you're struggling.
Why are you struggling?
KELLY: Because I'm going to mix them.
And then it won't be the same.
DAVID MALAN: Right.
So I mean obviously, this is
kind of a losing proposition.
You can't really do this.
What would make this easier for
you besides putting them back
in the bottles?
KELLY: Having another container.
DAVID MALAN: Yeah.
So you need like a temporary
storage space for this.
You know, let me--
Tara, can we get some
more cups over here?
Ah, this will make it easier.
OK, so if I get you
some temporary space--
here you go-- could you
solve the problem now please?
Ah, very nice.
A little contamination, but that's OK.
But I need that temporary
cup back for Tara.
Yeah, OK.
Thank you.
All right, a round of applause
if we could for Kelly here.
[APPLAUSE]
Well here we go.
I'm guessing you don't want
warm milk, but orange juice?
OK.
Thank you so much.
All right, so what's the point here?
This is pretty easy.
Like once you have
some temporary storage
space-- a variable, if you will, like
it's no problem to swap two values.
So let me go ahead and
do that as follows.
I'm going to go ahead and just
implement this swap function
and see exactly as Kelly
ultimately just implemented it.
If the goal is to swap a and b, I
can't just do a complete switcheroo,
it seems.
I need to put one of those values,
like the milk, in another container,
and then swap and then swap.
So it takes three steps, not just one.
All right, so I could call
this extra variable or cup
that Tara gave us
anything we want-- tmp.
So I'm just going to put a in tmp.
Then I'm going to put b in
a, because a is now empty.
Then I'm going to put tmp in
b, and then I don't really
care what happens to tmp-- indeed,
it's just still sitting there,
but the job is now done.
So let's go ahead and see this program
in action, because obviously this
should be pretty straightforward.
So let me go ahead and
open up this program
in the context of a main function
so we can actually run it.
In this code here, I'm going
to demonstrate it as follows.
Here's my main function.
I'm going to call variable x,
give it 1, call variable y,
give it 2, go ahead and just print
out just for a quick sanity check--
x is this, y is that.
Then I'm going to call this
super simple swap function, x, y.
Then I'm going to print the exact
same thing-- x is this, y is that,
just so I can see in those variables--
I could also use debug50, but this
is meant to be a complete solution,
I want to see it on the screen.
Here is swap.
I copy-pasted that from before.
This feels like a no-brainer,
super straightforward,
let's go into my directory and compile
this program, which, slight spoiler,
noswap is the name.
./noswap.
Oof.
Let's zoom in.
Nope, that is not what
I intended, right?
I really intended milk to
become OJ, OJ to become milk,
or x become y, y become x,
this doesn't seem to work.
And again, the only magic
is this one call to swap.
All right, maybe it just
works some of the time.
So nope, nope-- OK.
Now it's time for the debugger.
I don't understand what's
going on in my program,
printf is not really illuminating here.
So let me go ahead and
run debug50 ./noswap.
The little debugging panels
get opened on the side,
but wait, I need a breakpoint.
I'm going to start a breakpoint at the
very top, the first line I care about.
I don't really care about all
the stuff at the super top.
Now I'm going to go ahead and
rerun debug50 ./noswap, all right?
Now I see over here, the
first line 9 is highlighted.
Notice on the right-hand
side, and this perhaps
answers by example
your question earlier.
x and y conveniently, but just
because we're initialized to 0--
not by me, I shouldn't necessarily
trust this in all contexts,
but that's why they had values.
They're otherwise known as garbage
values, but I got lucky with 0's here.
Let me go ahead and step over that
line, and if you watch, albeit small,
on the right-hand side, x should
suddenly take on a value of 1.
And if I step over one more line,
y should take on a value of 2.
OK, so I'm pretty confident the
program is thus far correct.
I'm going to go ahead
and step over printf.
And notice the blue terminal
window, I see one output.
Now things get interesting.
If I continue stepping over lines,
it's just going to finish running
and that's not enough.
So notice this time I'm going to
hover over this third icon, Step Into.
Now I can kind of go
down the rabbit hole,
so to speak, and go into the
swap function, and notice,
the debugger jumps into
that other function.
So here now, the context changed.
My local variables are now a, b,
and tmp, and this is really weird.
A is 1, b is 2, as expected,
because I passed an x, y.
And in the context of this function
I'm just calling them a, b because.
But why is tmp 32,767?
It's just because it can't be
trusted, it's a garbage value.
If you just give yourself a temporary
value, who knows what's in there?
We got lucky and Tara did not
have anything in this cup,
but it could have had a garbage
value, maybe it had some Pepsi,
and then we would have had to
replace that value somehow.
So to be clear, when you
declare variables in a program,
quite often they have garbage
values, just bogus values--
the 0's and 1's that are there
underneath the hood in that chip,
but that you didn't set yourself.
But that's OK, because I'm explicitly in
this next line setting tmp equal to a.
So it doesn't matter what its original
weird value was, so if I click Next,
tmp is now 1, a.k.a.
a.
Now notice a is going to become b
if you watch the right-hand side.
Now I seem to have a is 2, b is 2, which
is a little worrisome but not as bad,
because I have that separate variable
tmp, so I still have the one around.
So now b is about to become 1,
and I've done the switcheroo.
OK, at this point in the story,
line 22, my code seems correct.
b has become a, a has become
b, and the values are swapped--
and the debugger is confirming
that for me visually.
So now, let's do a step and--
dammit.
Lost.
What is going on?
Intuitively?
Even if you've never seen or done this
before, like clearly there's a bug.
What is that bug?
What must be happening?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
a new value [INAUDIBLE]
doesn't have the same
address for the first one?
DAVID MALAN: Yeah.
What seems to be happening here
is yes, you're passing in x and y
and calling it a and b, but a and b
would seem to be copies of x and y.
And I am very successfully,
very correctly swapping a and b,
but because they're copies, it has
no effect on the original x and y.
So our metaphor here of
juice isn't quite apt
because I didn't pass Kelly
copies of the OJ and milk,
I handed her the actual OJ and milk
and she was able to change the values.
But in the context of C and code,
when you pass arguments to a function,
you're passing copies of those
arguments to the function.
So intuitively, what is the solution?
We clearly cannot pass from one function
to another copies of the values if we
expect the function swap, or a.k.a.
Kelly, to make some
useful change for us.
What do we have to pass to the
function or to Kelly instead?
The addresses of those values, right?
I told her where the milk and OJ were.
I didn't give her copies of them,
I told her, here's the milk,
here's the OJ, swap those.
In this version of the
code, I've just said,
here's a copy of x, here's a copy of
y, you can call them a and b-- um-mmm.
We need to now use the ampersand or
something like that to pass in a map,
if you will.
The treasure map to those values so that
swap can change the original values.
And the way we do this is
a little weird-looking,
but all we're going to have to
do is make a little addition here
that looks as follows.
It's got to look like this instead.
So this is the broken version.
Or broken in that it doesn't have the
effect we intend even though it works.
This is what we need to do
instead, and it's the last piece
of new symbology for today.
We've seen star in a
couple of different places
before, now we're using
it in one final context.
When you specify a star here and here
in the arguments to a function, that
is just the way you
tell the computer, I'm
expecting not an int, but
the address of an int.
I'm expecting not an int here,
but the address of an int.
So two pointers, two
addresses of integers.
Down here, tmp is still just an int.
I don't need to over think
tmp, that's just an empty cup.
Give me an integer
called tmp from week 1.
But, what do I want to store in tmp?
Both a and b in this
version are addresses.
Do I want to remember the
address a and the address b?
No, I want to remember the
volume of OJ, the volume of milk,
I want to remember 1 and 2, I don't
care where in memory they are.
So star in this context, when
there's no mention of a data type,
there's just a star and a variable name.
That variable is a pointer
and it's not multiplication,
there's no math going on.
That star is the dereference operator
that says, go to this address
and get the value there.
So if this address a is at location,
I don't know, 100 like Brian was,
and this address b is at
location 900 like Veronica was,
*a means go to the 100th byte in memory
and get me that value, which is 1.
This means, down here, go to the address
b, get me that value at address 900,
which is 2.
And go ahead and store 1 in tmp.
Go ahead and go to that
address and put whatever's
at b's address-- so get that address
and put it over-- get that address,
get the value, and put it over
at that address by dereferencing.
And then lastly, go to b in memory, like
over there, put the tmp value there.
So whereas ampersand in
our previous example means,
tell me what the address is of a
variable, star is the opposite.
When you have an address,
it says, go to that address.
Follow the treasure map, X marks
the spot at that location in memory,
and get at its value.
So what is the net effect here?
If I actually now open up not
this example, but swap.c--
spoiler, this one is
going to actually work.
If I open up swap.c, we're going
to see now the following instead.
The code is almost the same,
except that I pasted it
in this new green
version of the function.
And notice here, this had a change.
Why am I typing in %x now and
%y instead of just x and y?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] address
[INAUDIBLE] functions [INAUDIBLE]..
DAVID MALAN: Exactly.
The swap function now,
the new improved version
is expected two addresses-- stars.
Each star, a.k.a.
pointers, not just values.
So this means I know x and y are
actually integers from week 1.
Now I need the address
of x and the address of y
so that swap can follow
those treasure maps,
so to speak, and go to those addresses.
So now, when I run this program, this
is more like the metaphor with Kelly
where I told her where
the milk and OJ were.
Now swap and go to those
locations as follows. make swap.
Let me go ahead and
then do ./swap, Enter--
ah!
Now it seems to be working.
And we can see as much
even with the debugger.
Even though it doesn't seem to
be buggy, I can still use debug50
to see and understand my
program, if not obvious-- oh,
I still need a breakpoint.
Let's set a breakpoint as before.
Let's rerun debug50.
The right-hand panel will
open automatically for me.
And let's go ahead and see,
if I start stepping over this,
now I see that x is 1, y is 2,
printf prints as much on the screen.
Now I'm going to go
ahead and step into swap,
and now notice, it's a
little weird-looking,
because now a is an address
and b is an address,
but tmp is still an int with a
garbage value, but I can fix that.
Now tmp is 1, but notice, a and
b's values are not changing,
but what is clearly
changing per the code?
So notice, this is weird and cryptic.
a is this 0x value.
That's a big hexadecimal address,
like that is where in memory a is.
But you know what?
If I click the little triangle,
I can kind of follow that pointer
and go to it.
The debugger is smart like that.
So *a, go to a is 2; and *b at the
moment is 2, but if I keep going,
now I've done a switcheroo, and you
can see that these values have changed.
And again, we don't care
what these addresses are,
I don't care what the
actual addresses are.
I do care that it gives me this
functionality, because now when
I return up here in print,
now the values have indeed
changed as I expected this whole time.
All right.
That was complex, but hopefully clear
as to why it now works even though we've
made this code look more cryptic.
If not, any questions are welcome.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is that from
the spot where [INAUDIBLE]
DAVID MALAN: Uh huh.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] the
star [INAUDIBLE] pointers?
DAVID MALAN: Good question.
Do we really need to have these
ampersands here because we already
have the stars here?
Short answer, yes, for symmetry.
This is telling the function
what to expect on the way in;
this is what's telling the
computer actually what to send in.
So what are the actual
inputs to that function?
It has to be symmetric.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] value
is swapping addresses.
DAVID MALAN: We are swapping
what is at the addresses.
AUDIENCE: So what if you change
the address of [INAUDIBLE]
DAVID MALAN: OK.
AUDIENCE: And would we swap the
addresses saying 2 is at 200 and 1
is at [INAUDIBLE] that could change.
DAVID MALAN: Short answer, you
cannot for the following reason.
So technically, when you do %x and
%y, these are converted to the address
of x, the address of y.
Technically swap is getting copies
of something, C has not changed.
But C is now getting
copies of the address
of x, copies of the address
of y, calling them a and b.
So sure, you could swap the addresses,
but for the same reasons as before,
it's going to have no
fundamental effect.
The difference here is because
I'm passing in a map, so to speak,
to x and y, their addresses.
And again, an address is like--
we are at 45 Quincy
Street I think right now--
Cambridge, Massachusetts 02138, USA.
That uniquely identifies the building.
These 0x hexadecimal numbers uniquely
identify locations in memory.
So this is like saying now, get me the
address of x, get me the address of y,
and I'm technically passing in copies of
those addresses, but it doesn't matter,
because now with the star notation,
I'm saying go to those addresses
and swap who is physically in
this building and some other.
All right.
So let's just put this now
into the context of what else
your computer actually
has just that you've
seen some nomenclature around
this computer's memory.
So this is the chip with a
grid laid out on top of it
just to communicate that there's
bytes here, and we could number them.
But let's think about
this now more abstractly,
and let me just reveal that it
turns out that the computer treats
different bytes, different squares
in different ways just by convention.
It turns out that in
your computer's memory--
and this is all just an
artist's representation--
at the top of that chip
of memory, so to speak,
is the so-called text of your program.
This is a fancy and
non-obvious way of saying
the 0's and 1's that your code
have has been compiled into.
The text of a program is the
code you wrote in binary,
that's where it's loaded from memory.
So in macOS and Windows,
you double-click an icon,
that program is loaded into
memory I said last week.
It's literally loaded into the top of
your computer's memory conceptually.
What else?
Well the heap is the fancy name given
to the chunk of memory in which memory
is coming from when you call malloc.
So when I called malloc earlier to get
a bunch of space for some characters,
it was just coming from this
big open area called the heap.
And that's what get_string is
using and other functions as well.
Well it turns out that the reason
for the problem we just ran into
is because the bottom part of
memory is what's called the stack.
The stack is the area of memory that
functions use when they are called.
And this is actually relevant to that
very simple noswap example as follows.
If we now assume that anytime you
call a function, the memory it uses
comes from the bottom of
that big block of memory,
where you can draw that, for
instance, here on the screen,
because it turns out that anytime you
call a function, that function gets
a slice of its own memory.
So for instance, main is always
the first program a function calls,
and so it gets the first slice of
memory at the bottom of the screen here.
And so if main had two variables
x and y, that's like saying,
OK, give me a chunk of memory
called x and put the value 1 in it;
give me another chunk of memory,
call it y, put a value in it here.
But remember, from the first noswap
example, the swap function was called.
This is a stack in the literal sense.
You go into a dining hall, a cafeteria,
one tray for food, goes on another,
goes on another, goes on another
so that the humans can take it
and put food and plates on it.
Well similarly in this model,
when you call a function,
it gets its own slice of memory,
but literally above, conceptually,
the existing frame on the stack.
So this is the swap function's
own chunk of memory,
and it, too, gets some space.
It gets some space for
a variable called a.
a variable called b.
And guess what goes inside
those of that first example?
A copy of x and a copy of y.
And you know what?
It had a temp variable, so that's
got to have some space here.
So I'll call this tmp.
And recall that I set tmp
equal to a, so that got 1.
And then what happened?
Well then I did what--
what did I?
Let me get this right.
We had a gets b.
So what happened there?
So in this example here, a gets
the value b, so that changed.
And then what happens here, b got
the value of 10, so that changed.
So swap was working in the sense
that it was swapping values,
but the problem is, when a function
returns, this chunk of memory that it
was previously using gets reclaimed
so that someone else can now use it,
another function.
So we did all that hard work and
no swap, and we did it correctly,
we just did it in the wrong place.
So by contrast, this next example
that we did, which was swap.c,
just treated the memory
a little bit differently.
Main this time still had two
variables called x, and this was a 1,
and then another one
called y, and this was a 2.
And then one swap was
called this time, it again
had a variable called
a and a variable called
b, but what was stored in a and b?
Well now they're addresses.
And I don't know what it is, but let
me just arbitrarily say that this
is location 100, this is location--
let's say 104.
But it could be anything, we
just don't care at this point,
it would have 0x technically if
the computer were showing us.
What's going in a here is 100,
what's going in b here is 104.
And those are the addresses
of x and y, and the code
we had using all of those
new stars was saying,
go to address 100 and store
whatever is at address 100 in tmp.
Then go to the address
that's in b, or 104,
and store that at the location
int *a, whatever is there.
Then it was saying, go get
that 10th value, by the way,
and go ahead and put that
here, so that now we did
different work in a different place.
So now when swap is
done running, it doesn't
matter if its memory disappears
because it has now mutated or changed
the other memory.
That it was passed in just like
Kelly changed or mutated the cups
I actually pointed her at
rather than copies thereof.
Now as an aside, there's other chunks
of memory that are actually used.
If you have global
variables in a program,
turns out that in between
the text and the heap
memory are your global variables,
if they're initialized with values
or they're not initialized with values,
as would happen with the equal sign,
but we don't care too much
about that for today's purposes.
And if you've ever heard of
environment variables, which
we will when we get to web
programming, they, too,
are stored elsewhere in memory.
But the most interesting
chunks of memory
are stack and heap,
as in this case here.
But unfortunately it's so
easy for things to go awry--
I mean, some of you experienced
segmentation faults already,
and let's consider
why that might happen.
So here's a contrived example
of code that is by design buggy,
but let's just talk it through in
English what these lines are doing.
This line here, int *x,
is saying, hey, computer,
give me a variable that will
store the address of an integer.
So give me a pointer to an int is
the more casual way of saying it.
Hey computer, give me
another variable that's
going to store the address
of an int and call it y.
So x and y, that's it.
This line is new-ish.
Hey computer, allocate enough
space that will fit an int.
So sizeof int is the new syntax we
saw earlier for just figuring out
how many bytes is an int.
Odds are this is going to come back
as 4 or 32 bits in most computers.
So this just says, hey browser,
give me 4 bytes of memory
and store that in this location.
Or rather, store that in this
variable, store that this variable.
So maybe it's going to say, OK,
here's four bytes at location 100,
or here's four bytes at location 900.
Or wherever, we don't care, we're
just remembering that address in x.
*x says, go to that address--
100 or 900, whatever it is,
put the number 42 there.
This next line says, go to the address
in y and put the unlucky number-- hint,
hint--
13 there.
Well what is the address in y?
I haven't allocated it yet.
What's the address in x?
It's wherever malloc
told me to use space.
That's safe, that was like 100,
900, whatever the value was,
but did I allocate space for y?
So what kind of value does
it contain, so to speak?
A garbage value.
Maybe it's 0, maybe it's
like 32,000-- we don't know,
because if you don't
specify the value, it
is not safe to trust it
or do anything with it.
This is going to give me probably
one of those segmentation faults.
And indeed, if I run
a program like this,
I'm quite likely going to see
exactly that kind of problem.
It's perhaps better, though,
to see this in a way that
will paint a more memorable picture,
and for that, thought we'd take--
in our 10 minutes remaining,
use a few of these minutes
to take a look at something
our friends at Stanford
put together with a bit of claymation.
It's about three minutes
long, well worth it
to paint a picture of
exactly what goes wrong
when you don't use memory correctly.
If you could dim the lights.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Hey, Binky.
Wake up!
It's time for pointer fun!
- What's that?
Learn about pointers?
Oh goody!
- Well to get started, I guess we're
going to need a couple of pointers.
- OK.
This code allocates two pointers
which can point to integers.
- OK.
Well I see the two pointers, but they
don't seem to be pointing to anything.
- That's right.
Initially pointers
don't point to anything.
The things they point
to are called pointees,
and setting them up to a separate step.
- Oh right, right.
I knew that.
The pointees are separate.
So how do you allocate a pointee?
- OK.
Well this code allocates
a new integer pointee,
and this part sets x to point to it.
- Hey, that looks better.
So make it do something.
- OK.
How do you reference the pointer x to
store the number 42 into its pointee?
For this trick, I'll need my
magic wand of dereferencing.
- Your magic wand of dereferencing?
That-- that's great.
- This is what the code looks like.
I'll just set up the number and--
[POP]
- Hey look!
There it goes.
So doing a dereference on x follows
the arrow to access its pointee.
In this case, to store 42 in there.
Hey, try using it to store the number
13 through the other pointer, y.
- OK.
I'll just go over here to y
and get the number 13 set up,
and then take the wand of
dereferencing and just--
[BUZZING] whoa!
- Oh hey, that didn't work.
Say, Binky, I don't think
dereferencing y is a good idea,
cause setting up the
pointee is a separate step
and I don't think we ever did it.
- Mmm, good point.
- Yeah.
We allocated the pointer y, but we
never set it to point to a pointee.
- Mmm, very observant.
- Hey, you're looking good there, Binky.
Can you fix it so that y points
to the same pointee as x?
- Sure.
I'll use my magic wand
of pointer assignment.
- Is that going to be
a problem like before?
- No, this doesn't touch the pointees.
It just changes one pointer to
point to the same thing as another.
- Oh, I see.
Now y points to the same place as x.
So wait, now y is fixed.
It has a pointee.
So you can try the wand of
dereferencing again to send the 13 over.
- OK.
Here goes.
- Hey, look at that.
Now dereferencing works on y.
And because the pointers are sharing
that one pointee, they both see the 13.
- Yeah, sharing, whatever.
So we going to switch places now?
- Oh look, we're out of time.
- But--
[END PLAYBACK]
DAVID MALAN: All right.
So hopefully that puts a little more
visual behind some of these ideas,
but let's now contextualize
this in a domain that's perhaps
more familiar in a couple of ways.
So one, some of you might
already know, especially
if you've had prior programming
experience, of a very popular website
called Stack Overflow
where lots of programmers
post questions and hopefully answers
to common technical problems.
If you ever wondered why
it's called Stack Overflow,
it turns out it reduces
to this picture here.
This was not a mistake that I drew
one arrow from the heap pointing down,
and one arrow from the stack growing up.
As you malloc, malloc,
malloc more and more space,
starts up here, so to speak, and
you just get more and more space
that's going this direction.
But the more functions you
call-- function after function
after function after a
function, each of them
gets its own slice or frame of
memory, that, too, is growing up.
So this feels like a pretty bad design,
but honestly, it's not really avoidable
because if you have a
finite amount of memory,
you can't avoid each other forever.
And so there's this fundamental
risk of overflowing the stack,
or even overflowing the heap
in the reverse direction.
So Stack Overflow is an allusion
to, for instance, calling too
many-- many, many, many, many,
many, many, many, many functions,
so many so that it overlaps other
chunks or segments of memory,
thereby inducing a segmentation
fault, and buffer heap overflow
is in the reverse direction,
and these are more
generally known as buffer overflows,
and we'll see more of these in the weeks
to come.
But now that we have the
ability to discuss pointers,
let's introduce one final
feature and then a familiar face.
So it turns out that you can actually
come up with your own custom variables
kind of like we did with string, but
even more sophisticated than that.
For instance, if I wanted
to implement a program that
involves multiple students, I
might do something like this.
Ask the user what is the enrollment
in a class, then go ahead
and give myself an
array of strings, a.k.a.
char*s today of that size, and then I
could also have another array of dorms.
And I could have two arrays containing
one for the students' names,
one for the students' dorms, and
I can keep track of other things.
Another array for emails,
another array for phone numbers--
but this gets messy quickly,
because you can imagine,
if I need names and dorms
and emails and phones,
that starts to become
a lot of copy-paste.
And I just have this design where
I have lots and lots of arrays
where each bracket location--
like bracket 0, bracket 1
presumably refers to the same student
across all of these arrays, like mmm!
Messy, messy, messy design.
So with a wave of my
hand, let me actually
fix that immediate problem out of the
gate by introducing a new feature.
I can invent my own data types.
Let me just go ahead
and declare an array
called students with this many
students, but of data type student.
C comes with float, bool, char, int,
not string, and definitely not student.
So you can make your
own custom data types,
and you can put them in your own header
files, which we've not done either.
But I can look, and you'll see more
of this in the next problem set.
So not to worry if
this feels quite brief,
it's just meant to be a teaser here.
And struct.h is how you declare
or define your own type.
The keyword is literally typedef
struct for structure, or data structure
to be more complete.
The name of the data structure comes
at the end after some curly braces.
And then inside the curly
braces you just specify,
well what do you want a student to have?
I want them to have a name, a
dorm, maybe a phone number, maybe
an email address, anything I want.
I can just add here.
So that now in my actual code, I can
have an array of actual students,
and I can just access them with
this new notation like this.
You know that you can index into
an array with bracket notation.
What you didn't know until now,
perhaps, is that if at that location
is a structure, a.k.a.
struct, you can get at the name, the
dorm, or the phone, or the email,
or anything else there just by
using a dot-notation, which is
our last piece of new syntax for today.
Everything else is the same.
I can write a program that says so
and so is in such and such a dorm
by just saying get the i-th student's
name and the i-th student's dorm.
And I can be even fancier, and if I
don't want to just print those values,
I can even, now, that I see
no understand pointers--
or I've seen pointers and
we'll soon understand them
by way of problem sets and
practice, I can actually do this.
This is just a little sneak
preview of a line of code
that uses a new function called fopen.
fopen this file open, and it takes
in the name of the file to open.
You might know of CSV files,
they're like simple spreadsheets,
comma separated values.
And quote-unquote "w" means write.
So this says open the file called
students.csv in write mode,
so I can write to this file.
Because in this example, as
you'll see in the days to come,
I want to write out to a file.
But it turns out to use files, I
need to know what a pointer is,
and it's a little weird
that it's all caps,
but there is a data type in C
called "file," and it's a pointer.
So long story short, what you're
going to see in the next problem set
as we explore the world of
forensics is the ability
using pointers and a few new
functions to open files and get back
the address of that file in memory
so that you can go to that address,
change the contents of a
file, and save it back out.
All of us take for granted these days
that you can go to File, Open and File,
Save, but what's actually
happening, pointers are involved,
stuff's getting loaded into
memory, and the computer
is dereferencing or
going to those addresses
and changing what's at
those locations in memory.
Now why might you want to do this?
Well here, of course,
is Zamila-- you might
recall from some of the problem
sets and the walkthroughs.
Turns out we could try to enhance
this picture of her by zooming in,
and here's about as much
fidelity as it is in her eyes.
Like I do not see the glint
of any criminal's logo
on his or her jacket in
the glint of Zamila's eyes.
If you zoom in on an image, and
an image, recall, from week 0
is just a grid of pixels or
dots, that's all you get.
And you can maybe smooth it out a
little bit or clean up the colors,
but you can't just
"enhance," quote-unquote,
and see more of the
glint in Zamila's eye,
because an image at the end of
the day is just a bitmap, a map--
top-down, left-right-- of pixels.
For instance, here's a smiley face.
If you kind of take a look back and
you can kind of see a black smiley
face against a white backdrop.
And if we just decide as humans,
let's represent white dots
with 1's and black dots with 0's,
this might be what's in the file,
this is what the human sees.
So if we have the ability to open
that from a file, store it in memory,
and then using pointers go
to those locations in memory,
we can even change the smiley face to an
unhappy face, for instance, or color it
or do any number of things to it.
Now at quick glance, there's
a lot going on in files,
because what a file is is a set
of conventions that humans decided
on where humans years ago
just decided in a bitmap file,
BMP file-- so an older but still
popular file format for images, humans
just decided that, like, we're going
to put a bunch of special values
at the first bytes of
the file, then some more
special values than the actual RGB
pixels in the rest of the file.
So this is meant to look
cryptic at first glance,
and the next homework assignment
will walk you through this,
but all it is is a convention
of what the 0's and 1's mean
in these different locations.
And indeed, the challenge ahead is
going to be to do a number of things.
One is to first and
foremost figure out--
who done it?
A sort of murder mystery in which
there's a clue hidden in an image,
but an image that's a
little noisy and you're
going to have to figure out what
secret messages in the image
by loading that image in, tweaking
it, putting a sort of red filter
on top of it and seeing the secret
message, but all digitally; two,
actually resizing images and
taking this many pixels in this big
of a smiley face or something
else and making it bigger,
or if more comfortable,
making it even smaller
and figuring out how
to make that workout;
and then lastly, we've been taking
some photographs of all CS50 staff
in Cambridge and New Haven.
Unfortunately we accidentally
corrupted or lost the memory card,
but we made a forensic image of it, a
copy of all of the 0's and 1's with all
of the staff photos,
and we're going to need
you to write code that actually
recovers all of the JPEGs
or photographs from that
digital card by opening a file,
reading in those 0's and 1's,
understanding what they are
and where they are,
and just writing them
back out to disk using functions
we'll introduce you to in the problem
set itself.
But of course, all of this takes
for granted that we can do this,
and you can only do so much.
And indeed, this week is as much
about solving those problems
as it is realizing the
limitations of computers,
and so we thought we'd end with
the final few seconds of this very
real example from Futurama.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Magnify that death sphere.
Why is it still blurry?
- That's all the resolution we have.
Making it bigger
doesn't make it clearer.
- It does on CSI Miami.
- Ugh.
[END PLAYBACK]
DAVID MALAN: And that's it for
CS50, we'll see you next time.